So, ein bisschen früher als sonst.
Moin Fips, du bist auch echt immer am Start.
Ein bisschen früher als sonst, wobei, was halt nicht eigentlich genauso wie sonst, bloß dass es eine Stunde früher ist.
So rum, das ist eigentlich richtig.
Und warum soll ich noch eine Stunde rumsitzen, bloß dass es 9 ist, wenn ich wach bin.
Das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Muss mal kurz gucken, ob es wieder irgendwelche Raid Shadow Legends oder VPN Anfragen gibt.
Gucken, was Neues reingekommen ist.
Mal checken.
NordVPN.
Leute, ich hab wirklich jetzt hier die Klassiker schlechthin an Mails bekommen.
Leute, ich hab bekommen, Raid Shadow Legends Anfrage und NordVPN.
Lull.
Na dann ist jetzt alles klar.
Da kann ja nichts mehr falsch, schief gehen jetzt.
NordVPN.
Raid Shadow Legends.
Check ich mal weiter, lull.
Etwas früh.
Naja, mit Zeitumstellung ist es 9.
Also ne, ohne Zeitumstellung wäre es 9 gewesen.
Ja, Zeitumstellung ist es 9 eigentlich.
Aber Leute, ich hab NordVPN und Raid Shadow Legends Anfragen bekommen.
Das kann ich eigentlich mein YouTube Channel dicht machen, das hab ich alles geschafft.
Einfach easy sell out.
It's revealed.
Ne.
Das wäre ja was, was ich...
Also, was, was ich...
Machen möchte, was ich geschafft habe und nicht...
Ja, was ich nicht machen will, was ich geschafft habe.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, wirklich machen möchte ich eigentlich auch kein Placement für NordVPN oder für Raid Shadow Legends.
Wobei, NordVPN weiß ich jetzt schon, wie das laufen wird.
Wir antworten denen.
Die sagen ja, okay, so und so sieht's aus.
Und danach dann irgendwie ja so und so viel.
Machen wir was ab.
Und dann fällt ihnen ein, oh, ich hab ja ein VPN-kritisches Video bei mir hochgeladen.
Ja, dann soll ich das...
Dann soll ich das Video löschen.
Dann sag ich, nein, ich lösch das Video nicht und dann haben sie keinen Bock mehr.
Zumindest war das das letzte Mal so.
NordVPN.
Ganz ehrlich, brauchen tun's die wenigsten zumindest nicht für das, was sie denken, wofür sie es brauchen.
Aber gut, mein...
Genshin braucht auch keiner.
Wobei, das ist ja eigentlich ein ganz gutes Game ist.
Wenn halt nicht das Ganze reingecashe wäre.
Keo-Kon, danke schön.
29 Monate, massive subscription hier.
Ja, das ist einer der wenigen Sachen...
Ja.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Aber die...
Das Problem ist, was ich so sehe bei ganzen VPN-Anbietern ist,
dass da halt sonst was erzählt wird und die Leute das dann halt dann irgendwie auch für voll nehmen.
So nach dem Motto, ja, man ist viel sicherer im Internet unterwegs.
Die Hacker können nix mehr machen.
Vor allem, weil auch immer die Hacker sind, ja.
Dann irgendwelche...
Es wäre auf einmal alles verschlüsselt, was vorher nicht verschlüsselt ist.
Das ist halt alles ziemlicher Blödsinn, ja.
Ich meine, ja, okay, die Strecke ist verschlüsselt jetzt von dir zum VPN-Anbieter, aber danach genauso wenig wie vorher.
Und, naja, also...
So, so wirklich...
Also, ja, wenn irgendjemand noch wirklich offene WLANs ohne Client-Isolation oder irgendwas verwenden, ja, meinetwegen.
Oder wenn einer geoblockigen Sachen umgehen will, ja, das verstehe ich auch.
Aber viele Leute, so dieses Default, mach mal über VPN.
Das ist genauso wie unseren Azubi.
Wie man erzählt hat, er surft nur noch über Tor-Browser.
Habe ich ihm auch gesagt.
Also, du kannst von ausgehen, beim Tor-Browser, dass dort auf jeden Fall jemand deinen Traffic mitschneidet.
Man kann zwar nicht direkt rückverfolgen, wer du bist, aber da kannst du dir sicher sein, irgendjemand schneidet den auf jeden Fall mit.
Also, wenn du da was drüber machen willst, unverschlüsselt, dann kannst du von ausgehen, es ist mitgeschnitten.
So, ich mach gucken, wer Exit-Nodes betreibt bei Tor.
Gut, du kannst die auswählen.
Aber trotzdem, Jasper, dankeschön, sieben Monate Subscription.
Huge Subscriptions, Leute.
Nice, hu.
Ja.
Ja, musst du halt den richtigen auswählen.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
So diese, diese Sache, ich nehme Default Tor-Browser, ist nicht sinnvoll.
Genauso wenig, wie ich nehme Default und VPN.
Man kann das machen.
Es gab ja mal eine Zeit lang auch Gaming-VPNs.
Die waren tatsächlich...
Tatsächlich in beschränktem Maße noch sinnvoll, wenn du Kack-Routen genommen hast, irgendwie nach Asien für irgendwelche Games, falls Leute irgendwelche Asia-China-Chinesen-Games gespielt haben.
Oder auch nach NA teilweise, ja.
Ja, wenn du nach NA geroutet wurdest über Brasilien oder so, dann war das mit einem Gaming-VPN teilweise gar nicht so blöd.
Habe ich sogar mal kurzzeitig auch verwendet, als ich früher mal Dark auf einem US-Server gespielt habe vor.
12 Jahre oder so.
Nee, reicht gar nicht.
13 Jahre.
Null.
Auch nicht lang.
Das Team startet mitten in der Nacht.
Ja, komm, es ist 8.07 Uhr.
Gestern wäre es noch 9.07 Uhr gewesen.
Und ich bin trotzdem wach, obwohl ich gestern später ins Bett bin.
Das wird man auch überleben.
Unchristliche Zeiten, ja.
Brückentag oder Arbeiten?
Wie Brückentag?
Es ist Samstag.
Warum sollte ich Samstag arbeiten?
Äh, Sonntag.
Sonntag ist.
Null.
Vielleicht, weiß ich noch nicht.
Mal gucken.
Es ging ja darum, dass ich eine Skill-Liste erstelle für die Bewerbung.
Nee, ich habe es nur installiert.
Stimmt, heute ist Sonntag.
Aber Brückentag, wieso ist...
Ist morgen irgendwelche Feiertag?
Hessen?
Ist irgendwann auch noch Tag der Deutschen Einheit irgendwann?
Ah ja.
Das war schon.
Nee.
Das...
Doch, das war schon.
Das war Montag.
Das war Montag, Anfang Oktober.
Das hat mir nichts gebracht, weil Montag.
Also, die Deutsche Einheit hat mir schon was gebracht.
Aber dass es Montag ist, der Feiertag, hat mir nichts gebracht.
Dauert wieder bis Weihnachten, bis Feiertage sind.
Und dann fallen die Feiertage auch noch so beschissen.
Dieses Mal bringt es mir gar nichts.
Guck mal hier, Weihnachten, 25.
Der Kackel, Alter.
Montag, K-W-Tribble-U, Silvester ist dementsprechend dann auch ein Neujahr.
Oh, das ist ja richtig kacke.
Einzig Gute ist, dass der 24. dann ein Freitag ist.
Und dann ist das bei uns auch frei.
24. ist bei uns auch nichts.
In Hessen ist der 31. Feiertag.
Echt jetzt?
Warum?
Was soll das für ein Feiertag sein?
Nö.
Ist es nicht.
Ist nicht.
Ist kein Feiertag.
Also, wenn es bei hessen.de kein Feiertag ist, dann ist es kein Feiertag.
Ganz einfach.
Den 31.10.
Aber das ist kein Feiertag.
Sonst würde es da stehen.
Das ist die offizielle Seite von Hessen mit Feiertagen in Hessen 2022.
Dann kann das kein Feiertag sein.
Aber selbst wenn es irgendwo Feiertag ist, Montag würde mir eh nichts bringen.
Der 31. also morgen.
Weil montags arbeite ich nie.
Und dementsprechend finde ich es immer kacke.
Also, ich finde auch, dass Ostermontag nicht auf Montag fallen sollte.
Man könnte man ja ändern, Oster-Dienstag oder so.
Das wäre gut, aber warum Ostermontag immer an einem Montag sein muss, verstehe ich nicht.
Montag ist ein Kacktag für Feiertage, die bringt mir nichts.
Aha, sollen sie mal einführen.
Was ist eigentlich aus diesem Corona-Freitag geworden?
Gab es den eigentlich jemals?
Und im Jahr oder so war doch in Diskussion, mal irgendwie so einen Corona-Freitag zu machen.
Und den gab es nie, oder?
Ich glaube, da ist es nie dazu gekommen.
Gut, ich meine, irgendwelche Sachen, die man machen will und zu denen es dann nie kommt, gibt es ja massig.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es wirklich nächstes Jahr das 49 oder was es da noch immer Euro-Ticket geben wird.
Ich habe da auch meine Zweifel.
Sie haben jetzt zwar alle wieder ihre Absichten erklärt, aber das heißt ja noch lange nichts.
Oder wie wäre es mal mit der Zeitumstellung abschaffen, was man schon vor fünf Jahren machen wollte?
Ja, so hundertprozentig wach bin ich auch noch nicht.
Aber auch nicht wacher wie sonst.
Es ist ja immerhin schon neun.
Also, wäre es gewesen.
Oh, es ist gutes Wetter. Sekunde, Leute.
Ich muss mal kurz was checken.
Wie wird denn das Wetter heute?
Vielleicht kann ich heute ein bisschen ins Gebirge gehen.
Da sagen die Schweizer jetzt wieder Keckel, das ist doch kein Gebirge.
Aber.
So ein bisschen hier ins...
Hey, heute ist richtig gutes Wetter den ganzen Tag.
Pog.
Da müsste ich eigentlich jetzt nicht...
Also, ich hau jetzt nicht ab, ja.
Da müsste ich nachher mal so...
Mal zwei Stunden raus.
Weißt du, wie ist es morgen?
Morgen geht es so.
Okay.
Morgen ist so, naja.
Aber gut, man kann es ja noch ändern.
Das Schlimme ist, dass...
USA die Zeit eine Woche später umstellt.
Hä.
Pains Champ.
Tja.
Generell, ich finde, ich...
Also, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
Zeitumstellung und Zeitzonen finde ich immer noch komplett useless.
Einfach überall auf der Welt die gleiche Zeit und fertig.
Ich meine, wen juckt es, dass bei dem einen um zwölf Uhr die Sonne scheint
und beim anderen um 23 Uhr?
Das ist doch reine Gewöhnungssache.
Einfach Zeitzonen abschaffen.
Und Zeitumstellung abschaffen.
Fertig.
Wisst ihr, wie viele Probleme damit gelöst werden?
Ab auf die Wasserkuppe.
Nee, das ist nicht bei mir in der Nähe.
Also, bei mir am nächsten ist der Feldberg im Taunus.
Wobei das auch nicht so nah ist.
Spessart ist näher.
Nee, das sollen sie halt Ostermontag auch noch machen.
Ah.
Habe ich die Woche irgendwas verpasst?
War irgendwas Spannendes, Leute?
Komm, wir gucken mal kurz.
Gucken wir ganz schnell Github Trends.
Das mache ich ja immer einmal Sonntag.
Was denn so weekly getrendet?
Mal drüberscrollen und feststellen, dass ich wieder mit nichts was anfangen kann.
Okay, das habe ich gesehen.
Placingly fast written in Rust.
Irgendein neues JavaScript Build Tool.
Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht.
Leute, es gibt manchmal...
Ah, okay, okay.
Placingly fast written in Rust.
Es gibt manchmal Beschreibungen von Projekten.
Da weiß ich noch nicht mal, was das Projekt sein soll.
Ich meine ernsthaft, versteht das irgendjemand, was sie mir hier sagen wollen?
Next Generation Smart Contract Platform.
High throughput, low latency.
Asset-Oriented Programming Model, powered by Move Programming Language.
Was?
Also ich kann mir ja mit Ach und Krach noch was zu Smart Contract Plattform oder sowas.
Genau, Krypto-Krams.
Ich kann mir ja mit Ach und Krach noch was zu Smart Contract Zeug zusammen reiben.
Aber was sie mir mit dem Rest sagen wollen, habe ich keinen blassen Schimmer.
Und ich kann mir da auch nur zusammen reiben, irgendwelcher Krypto-Kram, ja?
Layer 1 for Everyone.
Was soll das sein?
Rust-Betriebssystem.
Ah, nee, Blockchain.
Das ist ein schlechter Name für Blockchain.
Da ist so S im Name.
Hätte irgendjemand an Blockchain gedacht jetzt, wenn er diesen Titel liest?
Ich hätte an irgendein Spielzeugbetriebssystem in Rust gedacht wieder.
Rust-Desk.
Sag mal, was ist da gerade angesagt?
Also Rust ist ja wirklich überall gerade.
Websocket-Server in C++.
Irgendwelches VPN-Zeug oder so in Go.
React.
Keypass.
Beste.
Android.
Machine-Learning-Kram.
PowerShell.
Next.js.
Orm-Mapper für...
Goorm, ein ORM-Mapper für Go, okay.
Flipper.
Zero-Firmware.
Das ist doch irgendein 3D-Drucker-Kram, oder?
Okay, es ist nix dabei, was mich irgendwie großartig interessiert diese Woche.
Neuer AI-Gamechase.
Laufend irgendwas.
Gamechanger.
Es ist genauso Gamechanger, wie Levelcap immer behauptet,
dass der nächste Battleground...
Battlefield-Patch ein absoluter Gamechanger ist.
Die sollen mal weiter gamechangen.
Ansonsten habe ich die Woche irgendwas Spannendes verpasst.
Erstmal überlegen, war irgendwas...
Kurz, kurz mal...
Als die News-Übersicht gucken, war da irgendwas Spannendes?
Die haben doch immer so eine Woche...
Ja gut, die Elon-Mask-Twitter-Geschichte ist gewesen.
Ähm...
Hatten die nicht immer so eine Wochenübersicht normalerweise jetzt?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Die China-Chinesen wollen...
Die China-Chinesen wollen irgendwas, das habe ich auch mitgekriegt.
I!
ABAP!
Ein ABAP-Kurs!
Okay, es gibt was, was ich mir wirklich nicht freiwillig geben würde.
Da müsste mich jemand für bezahlen, dass ich einen ABAP-Kurs mache.
Falls man das überhaupt so ausspricht.
Brennende Stromkabel.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil es minderwertige Qualität ist, oder so.
Also irgendwie nix Spannendes gewesen die Woche.
Nicht mal irgendwelche komischen...
größeren...
Windows-Fehler, oder irgendwelche...
Cloud-Hacks, oder war gar nix die Woche.
Heh, die Originalen, das war natürlich schlecht.
Gut, dass ich mir noch keine neue Grafikkarte gekauft habe.
Wie sieht es denn da aktuell kurz aus?
Ich schau mal kurz.
Also wenn ich im Dezember mir eine neue Grafikkarte kaufen will,
gäbe es da überhaupt was?
Ja.
Ja, gäbe es.
Ist halt teuer.
Teuer AF.
Gibt es Founders Edition noch?
Ne, ne.
Weil bei uns alles teurer ist.
Du kannst in der Regel...
Konntest du die letzten Jahre über schon sagen, 1 zu 1 der Euro-Preis.
Also 1 zu 1 der Dollar-Preis.
Eher nochmal irgendwie 15% obendrauf.
So, ja, ist das immer noch so.
Das ist teuer, ja.
Grafikkarten sind mega teuer.
Eher 2300, wenn du was kriegen willst.
Also ich rechne damit, dass mein neuer Rechner irgendwas um 4500 Euro oder so kosten wird.
Aber, was muss das wohl?
Wobei, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Es muss ja überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen...
Also überhaupt keinen...
Wirklich triftigen Grund, dass ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufe.
Ich meine, mein Rechner ist mittlerweile 5 Jahre alt mit einem 8700K oder 1080Ti.
Aber die Scheiße ist halt, es läuft alles.
Es gibt nix.
Es gibt nix, was nicht läuft.
Und es läuft auch alles relativ gut.
Gut, ich meine 1080p Gaming, ja.
1080p Gaming, kein Ding.
Ja, wenn es danach geht, brauche ich auch keinen neuen PC.
Aber ich hätte gerne echt wieder, also wirklich gerne mal wieder einen neuen.
Aber vielleicht mache ich es auch.
Vielleicht kaufe ich mir auch doch keinen neuen.
Wie gesagt, wir haben ja letztens einen zusammengestellt hier im Stream.
Ja, noch mit AMD.
Mal gucken, ob es auch AMD wird.
Vom Stromverbrauch her vielleicht AMD.
Weiß nicht.
Die Grafikkarte haut auf jeden Fall richtig rein.
Also, mal gucken.
Vielleicht kaufe ich mir auch keinen neuen PC.
Ganz ehrlich, 4500 Euro einfach nur, weil es nice ist, muss ja auch nicht sein.
Man kann es auch übertreiben.
Aber ich neige trotzdem noch dazu, einen neuen PC zu kaufen.
So, YouTube, was empfiehlst du uns?
Angular?
Ne, schon mal nicht.
Insane.
Skip.
Art Fire Ship, ein neues Video?
Next.
Ne, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Ist Coding dead?
Ähm, nein und wird es auch nicht sein.
Ich meine, seit 15 Jahren wird erzählt, demnächst können Manager auch irgendwas programmieren
und das hat noch nie geklappt.
Sei es von Excel angefangen bis irgendwelche Klick-Tools und jetzt irgendwelche Low-Code-Plattforms und sonst was.
Das wird einfach nicht passieren.
Was soll denn da rauskommen, wenn irgendwelche Manager demnächst programmieren?
Was soll denn da rauskommen, wenn irgendwelche Business-Software, die nicht richtig funktioniert oder was soll das sein?
Das klappt nicht.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich frage?
Wann endlich mal der neue ESP32 rauskommt mit ZigBee, Meta und Thread-Support?
Da gibt es ja zwei neue.
Ein ESP32H2 und ein ESP32C6.
Die sind schon seit über einem Jahr angekündigt, aber da tut sich nichts.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da, was mit, mit den China-Kinematen.
Ich weiß nicht, was da, was mit den Chinesen los ist.
Ups.
Das wird tatsächlich mal praktisch, wenn das Ding demnächst rauskommt.
So Leute, nachdem ich beide Anfragen jetzt habe für Raid Shadow Legends und für NordVPN,
sagt mir mal, was ich zuerst machen soll.
Wo soll ich zuerst drauf antworten?
Raid?
Raid oder NordVPN?
Oh, ich habe noch mehr Sachen sehe ich gerade.
Ich bin aber im Spam-Ordner gelandet.
Okay, das ist Scam.
Raid, die beste Zahl.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Okay, hier ist richtig, im Spam-Ordner ist richtig Scam.
Also am cringigsten finde ich die Mails immer,
wo dann irgendwelche
Publisher oder so
Mails rumschreiben.
Game XY jetzt
finally on Steam.
Und dann guckst du rein und es ist irgendwie so ein billiger
Mobile-Port von irgendeinem Game, was dich nicht juckt.
Die haben mich gefragt
bis jetzt. Genshin,
war das einzige Weeb-Game, was gefragt hat
bisher.
Excellent, Five Head Idee.
Das geht aber nicht, weil NordVPN
gesagt hat, sie wollen der einzige
Sponsor im Video sein.
Ansonsten wäre das Six Head Idee.
Also, für mich ist
immer so, ich mache
Sponsorings nur, wenn ich den
gerade nicht selbst spielen muss.
Das war auch bei World of Tanks
und sowas. Die wollten dann immer, dass ich selbst
Gameplay erspiele und sowas.
Ich will den Kram nicht spielen.
Ich erzähle da, ich reiße da 60 Sekunden
lang irgendwie den Text
runter. Irgendein
0815-Skript, wo jeder
hört, dass es halt irgendwie von irgendeinem
Cringe-Marketing-Typ geschrieben wurde.
Und dann ist gut, ich will den Kram nicht selbst spielen.
Und eigentlich wollte ich schon seit
fast einer Woche ein Video hochgeladen haben.
Zum
neuen Battlefield-Patch.
Da ist auch ein Sponsoring drin, aber die kriegen es mit ihrem
Sponsor, die kriegen es mit ihrem
Sponsor.
Reflink nicht auf die Reihe.
Raid Shadow VPN.
Bring die mal gar nicht, bring die nicht auf blöde Ideen.
Da weißt du nie, was passiert.
Okay, was gucken wir uns denn an? Lassen wir uns Level Cap
gebanen?
Modern Warfare 2, Missing Key Feature.
Okay, Level Cap.
Wir lassen uns einmalig Level Cap gebanen.
Und dann gucken wir uns
was Ernsthaftes an.
Ich skippe eh den meisten Krempel wieder.
Guck mal, der hat noch nicht mal Timestamps drin,
weil er genau weiß. Oh, doch hat er.
Aber mein Browser mag keine Timestamps.
Er hat
Timestamps verkackt, Level Cap.
Kecke. Weiß nicht, wie er das
geschafft hat, aber irgendwie hat er
Timestamps verkackt. So.
Komm, wir lassen uns eine Runde Level Cap
gebanen. Gut ist, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was diese Woche Neues gibt. Da kann ich auch gleich
die Sound-Lautstärke einstellen.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wann kommen Spiele heutzutage schon fertig raus?
Das ist wahrscheinlich viel teurer
und viel mehr in dieser Woche Gaming.
Hey Leute, Level Cap hier.
Ich habe das nicht vor drei Jahren gesagt,
als die, als die, als
die bei Microsoft angefangen haben
alle möglichen Sachen zu übernehmen
und den Xbox Game Pass zu packen.
Da habe ich damals im Video gesagt, gut Mann,
vielleicht war es ja einfach nur Glück, aber ich habe damals
im Video gesagt, pass mal auf, die werden das jetzt so attraktiv
machen, dass es jeder kauft und wenn es dann
die Leute haben, dann ist es einfach auf einen Schlag
übelst teuer. Mal gucken.
Captain Peng, Dankeschön für den Zap.
Alter, diese Map muss richtig
reudig sein. Ich habe das Game noch nicht gespielt,
nur runtergeladen, ja? Aber ich habe schon
so viele Twitter-Messages gelesen über diese
komische Autobrücken-Map.
Das muss wohl das neue Piccadilly sein, quasi.
Zap End, Dankeschön für den Zap.
Ist die das aus dem ersten Modern Warfare?
Ja, das ist ja was anderes.
Ja, die wollen nicht, die wollen nicht, dass
du Crossplay disablest.
Weil, wenn du Crossplay disablest,
beziehungsweise Crossplay disablen kannst,
dann steigt halt die Chance, dass wenn irgendeine
Plattform dead ist, dass dann keiner mehr drauf spielen kann.
Oh Gott.
Alter, wie lang geht denn das Sponsoring?
...
Hoffentlich kriegen sie es besser in als Half-Life mit Episode 3.
Ich sag euch, Warzone wird das Game eh wieder retten.
Nix Neues, nix Neues.
Die ganzen physischen, also viele physische Kopien von Games enthalten mehr oder weniger,
sag mal so, wenn überhaupt, enthalten die einfach nur was zum Downloaden.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile physische Kopien von Games, da ist einfach ein Steam-Code drin.
Da machst du das CD-Case auf und dann ist da ein Steam-Code drin.
Muss ich dir mal vorstellen.
Das ist das, was so aussieht wie Dead Space, oder?
Vorher diese Woche gab es ein Report über einen ehemaligen Call-of-Duty-Developer über die Spiel-Base-Matchmaking.
Er glaubte, dass das Spiel-Base-System die Erfahrung verursacht hat.
Ich bin kein Fan von SPMM. Ich mag es nicht, wenn Spieler...
Ja, okay.
Ah ja, okay.
Es gibt ja kaum eine SPMM-Befriedigung.
Ja, dass die Japaner irgendwelche Games bannen, weil 2Graphic ist mir auch neu.
Richtig.
So muss es meiner Meinung nach auch sein.
Im Ranked-Modus, selbstverständlich SBMM, dafür gibt es ja Ranked.
Es kommt aber auch immer ein bisschen auf das Game an, muss man sagen, ja.
Nur dass mich das Game so überhaupt nicht anspricht, jetzt auf den ersten Blick.
Oh, neue Kisten in Battlefield.
Es gibt jetzt übrigens auch orangene Container, habe ich gesehen, Leute.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Die haben nicht nur blaue, grüne, weiße, graue Container, die haben jetzt auch orangene Container und rote Container.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? Das ist fast, das ist nahezu unglaublich.
Spaß.
Ein Helm hat das Game gecrasht?
Na gut, bei dem Game wundert mich nix.
Ich mein, das ist immerhin schon eine Art Game.
Das wird zwar nie fertig,
ich glaube, sollte nicht die Kampagne schon vor drei Jahren erschienen sein.
... von der Game, um das Vulkan-API zu nutzen.
Das wird endgültig Unterstützung für Features wie AI-Upscaling, aka DLSS, Raytracing, Linux-Edition, VR-Bevorengung und viel mehr.
Die Devs sind fast fertig, die ganzen User-Devs zu portieren.
all the game's existing features and assets to the new render,
and it could potentially debut with the Alpha 3.18 update.
This version of Gen 12 is the basic implementation,
and development, refinement and added features will continue for years to come.
Spielt jemand von euch Star Citizen?
Das würde mich einfach mal interessieren.
Also ich will es jetzt nicht über Gebühren bashen oder so,
ich habe einfach keine Ahnung davon, aber es interessiert mich auch nicht großartig.
The live game performance should improve massively,
just don't expect an overnight improvement when 3.18 launches.
In other Star Citizen news, the developers just announced the Intergalactic Aerospace Expo 2952.
This is an annual in-game event that gives players a preview of upcoming ships
and also unlocks tons of ships for players to try out and buy.
It starts on November 18th and ends on November 30th.
Each day of the event will feature different ship manufacturers.
The teaser trailer also potentially has some hints at some new ships that may be announced.
Gotham Knights' first post-launch update fixed some specific issues,
but wasn't anything to get excited about.
They get how much of a cost of Xbox Game Pass and subscription services at some point.
But if the cost of Xbox Game Pass starts climbing,
he doesn't actually make.
It seems like the insane value of the Xbox Game Pass may not last forever.
During Microsoft's latest early call,
Xbox had Phil Spencer revealed that they'll have to raise the price of their hardware
and subscription services at some point.
He doesn't expect the price hikes to happen,
before this holiday season.
Spencer previously said the Xbox Series X and S would stay at their current prices,
so by hardware he might mean controllers and other peripherals.
But if the cost of Xbox Game Pass starts climbing,
it could put a significant dent in people's near universal praise of the service.
Microsoft announced that the Xbox brand made more money in the past three months
than it ever has in the first quarter fiscal period.
The problem, however, is that Game Pass has missed its growth target,
than it has missed its growth target in the last two years.
Microsoft targeted 73% growth for the service over the previous year,
but only managed 28%.
And so while it might seem like Microsoft is making more money than ever
and raising prices on players,
who knows what the actual investment of doing Xbox Game Pass has been.
Third-party testing by Igor's Lab has potentially identified the cause of the RTX 4090 power connectors melting.
Images of the melted connectors flooded social media this week.
The issue seems to be stress on the market,
and the connectors caused by PCK-
Bin ich froh, dass ich noch keine habe.
side panels since the card is so wide.
However, Igor's Lab believes the problem is isolated to the construction of NVIDIA's 12-pin to 4-plug SATA adapter.
The wires that supply the bulk of the connector's power are split across multiple pins.
Haben die das vorher nicht mal ausprobiert in irgendeinem, keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen Belastungstest oder so?
...with a solder plate and joint.
This connection is very fragile,
so if it gets stressed,
the split breaks,
sending the combined power of all six pins through just four,
which melts the connector.
The good news is,
the issue only affects NVIDIA's adapter and isn't a general issue with the 12-pin power connector.
So, you should be fine if your power supply actually has a native 12-pin cable.
NVIDIA are investigating the problem and should hopefully be sending replacement parts and offering repairs to address what Igor's Lab discovered.
The new character being added for season 15 of Apex Legends had her own power supply.
Ja, 2.000 Euro GPO, die sparen wir aber nachts.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Der Cent, der gesparte Cent macht's aus.
Also verdient schon.
Bringt Money.
Nächste Story? Der Kerl hat nur noch eine Minute Zeit.
Ach so, Lifetime. Ich wollte gerade sagen, dass es so gehypt ist, gerade hätte ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Der MVP-Fokus und die Lack der interaktiven AI haben sofort die hardcore-Fanbase der Franchise entfernt.
Die neuen Spieler der Franchise waren auch frustriert, weil Impalanz-Operator-Menschen...
... Mechanics, Bugs und die generelle Lack der Polarität des Spiels.
Aber die Devs haben einen Monumentalfall gemacht, um das Spiel aufzuparieren.
Vielleicht macht ja mal der Internet-Historian ein Video zu The Engoodening of Rainbow Six Siege.
Du bist damit wahrscheinlich nie warm geworden.
Klar, ist bestimmt für viele abstreckend, wenn du erst mal 200, 300 Stunden spielen musst, dass du halbwegs brauchbar bist.
The most legendary programmers of all time.
Hey, wollen wir wetten?
Der Dude hier links, das ist der C++-Erfinder.
Wobei ich halt es ihm immer noch übel nehme, C++ erfunden zu haben.
So, also was kann man als nächstes sagen?
Und was ist das hier?
Kindheitstraum.
Bagger reparieren.
Was verdient ein Baumaschinen-Mechatroniker?
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Was will er denn hier eigentlich?
Die ganze Serie Moneymaker...
Ich will nicht die ARD-Mediathek gucken.
Baumaschinen-Mechatroniker.
Der hat richtig gemacht.
Der hat auch nichts mit Holz gemacht.
Ups.
Was ist das?
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal das da.
Vim as your editor.
Oh ne, heute, heute morgen nicht.
Ne.
Das ist Werbung davor.
Das waren die schon Werbung für ihren eigenen Kram da drinne.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Das ist eben der Kindheitstraum so ein bisschen.
Der kleine Junge, Bagger, Bagger, LKW, LKW.
Ich hab mir früher, als ich klein war, auch sehr gerne Bagger angeguckt.
Ich mein, wer nicht.
Aber auf die Idee gekommen, Bagger beruflich zu bauen, hätte ich jetzt eher keinen Bock.
Darum geht es, mit einfachen Sachen Geld zu verdienen.
Dann ist man hier ein bisschen falsch.
Ja.
Kann man sich so vorstellen.
Ein paar blöde Bescheuerte treffen sich und knallen durch den Wald.
So ist halt Rallye auch.
Hi, ich bin Joe Bauer.
Bin 23 Jahre alt.
Lass das mal nicht Fridays for Future auf Twitter sehen.
Und arbeite als Baumaschinenmechatroniker in Umkirch.
Und jetzt bauen wir mal zu mir auf die Arbeit.
Jetzt bauen wir nen Bagger.
Entweder ich fahr in die Firma, muss noch irgendwas richten.
7.15 Leute.
Guck mal, der ist seit eineinhalb Stunden schon auf der Arbeit.
Heute ist Sonntag.
Aber jetzt, wo wir hier sitzen, der wäre seit eineinhalb Stunden schon auf, auf dem
Weg hier.
Ich fahr dann auf die Baustelle.
Oder ich rede hier.
Oder ich richte meine Sachen schon abends.
Fahr gleich am Morgen schon auf die Baustelle.
Moin, moin.
Meistens treffen wir uns hier morgen und werden erstmal eingeteilt auf den Baustellen.
Baumaschinenmechatroniker.
Also Baumaschinen reparieren, warten, pflegen und verteilen.
Was mit YouTube passiert ist, das ist ein neues Design und bei YouTube ist es ja immer so ein bisschen random, wer was kriegt.
Du kannst ja mal Cache leeren oder einen neuen Browser verwenden oder so, dann sollte es bei dir auch so sein.
Das ist random so ein bisschen.
Eben auch Einweisungen geben für einen Baggerfahrer, der die Maschine noch nicht kennt, wenn sie neu ausgeliefert wird.
Jetzt gehen wir erstmal an eine kleinere Maschine, an einen Yamaha Baggerfahrer.
Ich finde das neue gar nicht schlecht.
10 Tonnen, da müssen wir einen Schlauch abdichten und...
Easy, nur 10 Tonnen.
...da müssen wir noch was zu tun haben, oder ob es das schon war.
Könnte der Chad bestimmt auch reparieren.
Chad kann mit Schwarmintelligenz alles.
Servus, Morgen.
Hi.
Servus.
Joe, hi.
Was genau ist das Problem?
Twitch Repairs Bagger, das wäre doch mal ein Stream.
Der Schlauch.
Kaputter Schlauch, das ist schlecht, da geht er nicht mehr.
Dann bauen wir ihn wieder dran, wenn wir ihn original haben.
Jetzt mache ich die Entlüftung vom Tank aus.
Da musst du aber echt Plan haben.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht...
Es ist ja nicht, als gibt es nur zwei Bagger.
Okay, aber wahrscheinlich funktionieren die alle relativ ähnlich.
Das ist einfach nur, dass der Tankdruck verschwindet und dass wir keine Probleme haben mit Hydraulikdruck.
Da muss man schon ein bisschen wissen, was man macht, warum man kommt bei der Sache sein.
Also, weil wenn du da...
Ich weiß nicht, da ist bestimmt ordentlich Druck drauf.
Wenn du da irgendwie an der falschen Stelle was öffnest und stehst davor, dann pustet es dich erstmal gut.
Das ist halt einfach ein Heidenspaß.
Ich glaube, das...
Der Hauptgrund, warum ich das mache, ist eben das Kindheitsgefühl.
So große Maschinen.
Wir haben früher im Sandkasten mit dem Bagger gespielt und heute spielen wir halt mit dem richtigen Bagger.
Ja, aber warum nicht?
Da hat sich jemand Mühe gegeben.
Das ist mal ein ordentlicher...
Wie heißt das? Schraubenschlüssel?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich auch so ein Set von, aber...
Also, ich hatte mir mal so ein Vera Joker Schlüsselset gekauft.
Mega teuer, aber super nice.
Wenn man sie mal braucht.
Aber das ist ein ganz anderes Kaliber.
Da hätte ich nichts, was da dran passt.
Maulschlüssel, ja genau.
Da hat sich jemand Mühe gegeben.
Ich glaube, die arbeiten agiler als in der IT, wo die Leute sagen, sie arbeiten agil.
Weil da musst du wirklich dynamisch gucken, was Sache ist.
Die sind...
Die labern nicht nur agil, die sind agil.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir nur kurz gucken, wie viel Öl uns da entgegenläuft oder eben auch nicht.
Komplett.
Bagger läuft aus.
Man weiß ja, was auf einen zukommt.
Schmierig, schlechtes Wetter, draußen dreckig.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, 75...
45 Stunden, Alter.
Der hat doch gut was zu tun.
Man sich darauf vorbereitet.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe wirklich, dass der viel Geld verdient damit.
Dann passt das.
Will mal jemand probieren, ob alles passt soweit.
Passt.
Betrau dich, Öl ist auf voll.
Ja, passt.
Genau.
Gut.
Ich würde gerne auf jeden Fall...
...meinen Meister irgendwann machen.
Wann steht noch in den Sternen?
Hat man dieses komische Leisten-Ding da?
Ah, jetzt ist es weg.
So.
Suchen wir mal den neuen...
Guck mal, 9.30 Uhr und er hat schon den Bagger repariert.
Da überprüfen wir einmal alle Flüssigkeiten, ob alles passt, ob alles richtig schön zusammengeschraubt wurde.
Einfach alles einmal, bevor die Maschine das erste Mal rausgeht auf die Baustelle.
Erst mal Jira-Ticket aufmachen, wenn der Bagger nicht geht.
Genau.
Liefermaschinen, eigene Liefermaschinen.
Wir haben einen großen Fuhrpark mit Maschinen.
Und vermieten die natürlich, haben einen Mietpark mit Großgeräten, natürlich auch mit Kleingeräten.
Also von uns kann man alles von der Rüttelplatte bis zum großen Bagger alles ausleihen.
Natürlich verkaufen wir auch Maschinen.
Wow.
Da meine Eltern selber...
Gut, ich meine, natürlich ist ein Bagger teuer.
Das ist ein Riesending mit viel Technik und es wundert mich nicht, dass ein Bagger ordentlich Geld kostet.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, man kauft sich ja auch nicht einfach mal random einen Bagger, weil es einem danach ist.
Man will ja auch was damit machen.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal gemacht habe, aber wenn ich das mal gemacht habe, bin ich schon häufig in meinem Leben Bagger gefahren.
Für mich war es kein Problem.
Ich denke, wenn man am Anfang neu draufkommt, ist es wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen ungewohnt.
Aber die Maschinen, die sind sehr schön zu fahren.
Also da kommt man schon relativ schnell rein.
Da haben wir ein Protokoll, das wir jetzt einfach mal Schritt für Schritt durchgehen.
Und wenn wir das durchgegangen sind, ist die Maschine sozusagen einmal durchgecheckt und fertig für den Einsatz auf der Baustelle.
Und danach erst mal Daily-Scrum.
Was hat er für einen Akkuschrauber?
Bosch-Akku.
18 Volt.
Ja, das sind die Dicken.
Also, gecheckt haben wir alles.
Passt alles soweit.
Kommt jetzt noch Mietpark-Aufkleber drauf, dass man auch weiß, von welcher Firma sie sind.
Genau.
Und dann, wenn es der Mietpark zulässt im Büro, kann die Maschine ausgeliehen werden und ist einsatzbereit für die Baustelle.
Meist auch was dabei.
Überleg dir mal, wie viel der schon geschafft hat.
Und es ist erst mal zwölf.
In der Zeit haben die ganzen Leute aus diesen, ich zeige euch heute meinen Software-Entwicklungs-Job,
haben die Kaffee gemacht, haben eine Runde Tischkicker gespielt, Daily-Scrum und vielleicht nochmal irgendwie einen Code-Editor aufgemacht.
Zumindest in den Videos.
Realistisch ist es ja auch nicht.
Aber in den Videos sieht das immer so aus.
Der schafft wenigstens was.
Also, wie gesagt, so Leute brauchen wir.
Guck mal, es ist aktuell.
So schwierig beispielsweise Handwerker zu bekommen, wenn du dir einen Zaun bauen lassen willst oder wenn du dir irgendwas an der Klimaanlage am Haus bauen lassen willst,
irgendwas am Fenster, an der Tür, was auch immer.
Oder sei es nur einfach ein Ladegerät für das Elektroauto.
Das dauert Wochen und Monate, bis du da Leute bekommst.
Also Handwerker brauchen wir unbedingt.
Und deswegen hoffe ich auch immer, dass die so viel verdienen, dass sie alle glücklich mit sind und das weitermachen, beziehungsweise noch mehr Leute machen.
Wie ist das eigentlich rein?
Wir brauchen viel weniger Management-Bullshit-Shops.
Mehr sowas.
Oft unterwegs, wenn es da mal was gibt, wenn man halt nichts dabei hat.
Also immer wieder unterschiedlich.
Genau, aber heute gehen wir mal in den Kramer.
70.
Boah, die kommen aber alle mit wenig Geld aus.
70 Euro kann ich theoretisch schon für eine, kann ich eine Woche in Frankfurt Mittagessen ausgeben.
Monatlich, das ist ja nix.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich, wenn ich wirklich.
Komplette Woche nach Frankfurt fahren würde und da jeden Tag essen, bin ich auch bei 70 Euro.
Oder ein, einen großen Döner Teller.
Nee, ähm.
Wobei, naja, nicht ganz, also.
Mittag, es haben ja viele Leute, äh, viele Restaurants, meine ich, viele Restaurants in Frankfurt haben ja immer noch so Mittagskarten und sowas.
Da kannst du immer noch für, sagen wir mal, 8 Euro, 8,50 oder sowas futtern.
Aber trotzdem.
Da hast du in zwei Wochen hast du das.
Und dann musst du dich, da darfst du schon nix zu trinken mehr dabei bestellen und so.
Baggerkette ist kaputt.
Da ist einfach nur ein Kettenglied gerissen und das wurde jetzt einmal getauscht, weil gebrochenes Kabelglied ist natürlich nicht gut.
Das wird, genau, das wird immer schlimmer und irgendwann prägt es und dann fliegt die Kette neben den Bagger und das ist nicht gewollt.
Da hast du was zu tun.
Ja, genau.
Wichtig ist eben, wenn man die Kettenplatten, bevor man sie wieder drauf macht, das ist alles schön.
Eben abgeschleift wird, dass da kein Rost, keine Farbpartikel, keine Dreckpartikel drunter sitzt, dass es alles schön nachher wieder drauf sitzt.
Weil es wird nachher mit Drehmoment angezogen und wichtig, dass es halt eine gerade Oberfläche hat.
Alter, die Musik, Alter.
WTF.
Pa-pa-pa-pa.
Skrrr.
An handwerklichen Sachen, da darf man natürlich nicht so rückschrecken.
Jemand, der beim Funken gleich zurückschreckt und da schreit, den kann man.
Kann man wahrscheinlich weniger gebrauchen.
Hier, Funken, Leute.
Ich habe vor nicht allzu langer Zeit das erste Mal Metall durchgeschnitten selbst und ich war überrascht, dass es Funken sprüht.
Also wenn man Metall durchschneidet, sprüht es Funken.
Das hätte ich eigentlich wissen können, aber das war mir so nicht klar.
Und jetzt weiß ich es.
Aber da habe ich auch gedacht, huch, was ist denn das?
Aber passiert ja nichts.
Maschine natürlich.
Ein paar tausend Stunden schon drauf, ist im Steinbruch gelaufen, deshalb reiht sich alles ein bisschen aus und dehnt sich ein bisschen aus.
Deshalb müssen wir jetzt die Schraubenlöcher ein bisschen anpassen, da halt ein neues Kettenglied drin ist.
Guck mal, der gute, der gute Werra Kraftform Schraubendreher da unten.
Seht ihr ihn?
Ja, passend so ganz, wie es soll.
Deshalb beschleunigen wir das Ganze, dass wir das noch stundenlang machen.
So geht es ein bisschen schneller.
Ja.
Da war noch kein Ding.
Und den Rest ein bisschen wegfräsen.
Und dann abschleifen.
Ist auch nicht immer schön, an schweren Ketten zu arbeiten.
Also nicht immer einfach.
Aber du fühlst dich halt gut, wenn du zu Hause bist und du weißt, du hast gerade so eine riesen Kette gemacht, gewechselt.
Beziehungsweise in dem Fall jetzt repariert.
Alter!
Das ist mal so ein Drehmomentschlüssel.
Hoho!
Hohoho!
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja ein 1,5 Meter ist das Teil.
Das ist mal einer, hä?
Kannst du ordentlich anziehen.
Ich verdiene 3200 brutto.
Genau.
Dazu kommt natürlich noch Überstunden.
Ähm.
Und das wie oft im Jahr?
Dazu, das sind so Durchschnittlich...
Sag da auch wie viel Jahresgehälter, äh wie viel Monatsgehälter.
400 Euro.
Und am Ende des Monats bin ich damit netto bei...
Also 3500 mal 12.
Na, mal 14 wäre okay, würde ich sagen.
Ja, aber das ist trotzdem, also, der dürfte, der dürfte ruhig mehr verdienen, ja.
Also nicht, nicht, dass ich da jetzt irgendeinen Einfluss drauf hätte.
100 Euro ungefähr.
Mit dem Geld bin ich zurzeit sehr zufrieden, da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht beschweren.
Wirklich überhaupt nicht.
Das ist, äh, auf jeden Fall nicht in Stein gemeißelt, das variiert sehr.
Natürlich, wie lange man da ist, wie viel Erfahrung man hat.
Jeder Baumaschinenhersteller bietet Lehrgänge an, desto mehr Lehrgänge, desto besser kennt
man die Maschinen.
Umso mehr Geld?
Umso mehr Geld.
Und das liegt mir natürlich dann auch.
Genau, so ist es.
Morgen muss ich einen Kundendienst machen.
Ist das noch Windows 7?
Leute, ist das noch Windows 7?
Das ist ja antik hier.
Wartungsplan raussuchen, morgens nur ein kleiner Rad.
Der wird bestimmt nicht mehr, wird bestimmt nicht mehr supported.
Vista?
Wie kommst du auf Vista?
Stimmt, das ist IE, IE 7 oder sowas, ja.
Raussuchen, morgens nur ein kleiner Radlader.
Die Teile.
Den haben wir gleich.
Ja.
Gleich mit.
Dann haben wir jetzt alles drin und machen jetzt Feierabend.
CU.
Das war das Vista-Logo, okay, das ist ja wirklich antik.
Hallo.
Nimm ich mal um kurz.
Meine Freundin studiert, arbeitet auch nebenbei, aber den meisten Teil zahl ich natürlich,
weil ich verdiene auch das Geld.
Also wir haben eine Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung, das sind schätzungsweise 90 Quadratmeter.
Für den Freiburger Wald.
Für den Freiburger Raum kann ich mich überhaupt nicht beschweren, ne, da bin ich total zufrieden.
Ist es teuer in Freiburg?
Ich habe keinen Plan.
Relativ zeitintensiv.
Ich fahre Rally seit 2021, da bin ich mein erstes Rennen, mein erstes Motorsport-Event
gefahren und da habe ich mich auch wirklich drin verliebt und möchte auch nichts anderes
machen.
Boah, der hat aber Energie, Alter.
Am Tag irgendwie 8,5 Stunden arbeiten und dann auch abends Rally fahren bzw. üben oder
was auch immer.
Also der wird ja nicht abends, aber der wird wahrscheinlich üben.
Und dann auch abends Rally fahren.
Oder am Auto rumbasteln und sonst was.
Boah, da hast du...
Boah, das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich hatte noch nie Angst, mich selber zu verletzen.
Ich hatte immer nur Angst, dass ich mir mein Auto kaputt fahre.
Und das mache ich immer.
Ich habe gar keine Gedanken.
Ganz ehrlich, das Gefühl kann ich nachvollziehen.
Das passt schon alles irgendwie.
Eigentlich, sobald er ins Auto einsteigt, ist es eine Katastrophe.
Es ist Herzrasen, Freude, Angst.
Als ob bis jetzt noch nichts passiert.
Nicht ungefährlich, der Sport.
Die sind zwar mega geschützt.
Aber wir haben schon einige Unfälle gesehen und es kann halt auch nicht so schön ausgehen.
Jetzt geht es nach Offenburg in die Rallye-Werkstatt, wo wir unsere Rallye-Auto stehen haben.
Da haben wir das Auto ab, mit dem wir gestern gekommen sind von der Rallye und bereiten das
Auto für die nächste Rallye vor.
Also der hat wirklich hartes Tagesprogramm.
Gehen wir los zur nächsten Rallye.
Also das Auto gehört meinen Eltern.
Das kaufe ich quasi monatlich ab.
Tanken müssen wir relativ viel, weil wir halt am Wochenende immer viel unterwegs sind
und auch weite Strecken zurücklegen.
Ich darf nur Rallye fahren, solange ich auf dem Führer stehe.
Das ist bestimmt bei den Eltern versichert, weil es billiger ist, oder?
Ja, weil es auch eben auf öffentlichen Straßen gefahren wird, auch die Verbindungsetappen.
Chat, das ist natürlich...
Ich kann mich nicht beschweren, wie oft hört man diese Worte von einem ITler.
Selten.
Wir können uns über alles dauerhaft beschweren.
Ich auch.
Mach ich ja im Stream zu 90 Prozent.
Der Führerschein wäre es dann erstmal vorbei.
Deshalb ist der Führerschein das Heiligtum.
Ja.
Monka Stier.
Der ist laut.
Der ist schön laut.
Aber macht auch echt Spaß mit dem Auto.
Ich glaube, könnte das sein, dass...
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Autos und Autorennen.
Aber könnte das sein, dass die so laut sind?
Also natürlich, weil es ein fetter Motor ist, aber auch weil da halt nichts an Isolierung
oder sonst was dran ist.
Dass es möglichst leicht ist.
Da ist doch wahrscheinlich alles außer das Nötigste, was du brauchst am Auto, weg.
So geil, das Ding.
Bei der Rallye schaue ich nicht aufs Geld.
Das, was sein muss, muss sein.
Gute Sachen kosten Geld.
Bei der Rallye gibt es eigentlich nichts Billiges.
Deshalb schwierig.
Irgendwann später vom Rallye fahren leben.
Das wäre natürlich ein absoluter Traum.
Aber ob ich das jemals so weit schaffe, steht noch in den Sternen.
Der V-Maschinen-Mechatroniker, der Rennfahrer.
Das sind zwei Sachen, die sich miteinander sehr, sehr gut verbinden.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Von großen Maschinen, von großen langsamen Maschinen zu schnellen kleinen Autos.
Das ist schon ein guter Gegensatz.
Und ja, der Kick, der macht es halt vor allem aus.
Der Adrenalinkick im Rallye-Auto, das macht schon wirklich Spaß.
Ein bisschen leiser.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Wenn es nach mir geht, könnte er ruhig deutlich mehr verdienen.
Aber ich darf es ja nicht entscheiden.
Was wir Baumaschinen-Mechatroniker in der Werkstatt oder auch auf der Baustelle draußen machen.
Wenn ihr Mechatronik sogar studieren wollt, klickt mal hier.
Und falls ihr mehr Mechatroniker sehen wollt, die Rennen fahren sogar, klickt hier.
Nope.
Haben die vielleicht noch was anderes, was man...
Das ist ja mal ganz gut. Irgendwas, was vielleicht auch ein bisschen so mit...
Dating und Partnersuche ohne App.
So arbeitet eine Partner...
Oh, ne, please.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Was verdient ein Kundendienstherrchen?
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Den Rest haben wir auch schon alles geguckt.
Partnervermittlung. Gibt es sowas überhaupt noch offline?
Macht das jemand offline?
Also, ich habe euch ja mal erzählt.
Mein Vater hatte früher auch eine Partnervermittlung.
Und dann hat die Leute gescampt.
Also, wenn ich sowas lese, verbinde ich damit schon Scam.
Aber sonst irgendwas Spannendes hier.
Party im Kult-Discounter.
Mein Gott, was wird denn wieder abgehen?
Das sind so kleine...
So Videos...
Die haben vielleicht einen ansprechenden Titel.
Aber interessiert mich so gar nicht.
Wenn ich die Titel schon lese, habe ich keinen Bock.
Abgezockt. Wir testen den Gaming-PC von Netto.
Aber RGB.
Mittlerweile haben auch Billig-PCs schon RGB.
Is your PC hacked?
Sicherlich.
Der Chat hackt laufend meinen PC.
Stimmt's?
Aber was können wir uns sonst noch angucken hier?
Is coding really dead?
Was?
What would happen if you swiped the water chat?
What?
Ich glaube, das Video habe ich aufgemacht, weil das vorher in der Empfehlung drin war.
Ja, dann zeig doch mal.
Was passiert, wenn man den Water Chat swiped?
Wie waren die Aufrufe?
Die Aufrufe der einzelnen Berufe.
Zeig mal her.
Ja, schwankt schon.
Der Jäger! Guck mal, der Jäger
hat richtig viele Aufrufe.
Das Video mit dem Jäger hat mich verwirrt.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Da hat er in dem Video irgendeinen Reh erschossen
und danach dem Reh
so einen Zweig in den Mund gesteckt.
Und meinte, das ist gute alte Jäger-Tradition.
Ich dachte mir so, what?
Hä?
Als würde das das erschossene Reh noch irgendwie interessieren,
ob es jetzt einen Zweig im Mund hat oder nicht.
Das war doch die, die den ganzen Tag nur
Excel-Tabellen gemacht hat, oder?
Selbstständige Excel-Tabellen-Erstellerin.
Okay, also.
Was passiert, wenn man den Waterjet swipet?
Alles klar.
Das ist ein Video, wo wahrscheinlich 3 Sekunden
was passiert.
Wie findest du das neue YouTube-UI?
Ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal so kacke.
Also die letzten Überarbeitungen waren immer schlechter.
Jetzt
finde ich in Ordnung.
Wir gucken mal, also wo wird der Finger
geswiped?
Every time the waterjet is running,
there's a weird primal urge to swipe your hand
as fast as you can
see how bad it would hurt.
Would it be a slight score?
Would it tear through your hand?
Also je nachdem, was das für ein Wasserstrahl ist,
oder wie nennt man das auf Deutsch?
Wasserschneider oder so? Keine Ahnung.
Würde ich mal von ausgehen,
das geht bis auf die Knochen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es deine Knochen
komplett durchschneidet,
wenn du es einfach nur drunter durchziehst,
aber so hier, ähm,
Adern, Bänder,
sonst ist wahrscheinlich alles durch.
Schon das Battlefield
2042 Video gesehen.
Wasserstrahlschneider, genau.
Nö, ich habe aber viele Battlefield-Videos gesehen schon.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt schon gesehen habe.
...mainly involving the waterjet,
but I'm quite impressed,
there's even a skin pattern on these.
Ich spule jetzt mal vor,
weil solche Videos sind
10 Minuten Gelaber und 3 Sekunden
Spannendes.
Okay, we're gonna start with a swipe.
Imagine I was adjusting something on the jet
and it accidentally slipped and went.
Yeah, or
you gave in to the primal urge
and you just...
Also ich hätte keinen Urge, meine Hand da drunter
durchzuziehen.
You wrist it all.
Au!
I wonder how that got out there, but...
Well, you'd be missing the tip of your...
Ja, okay, die Finger ist natürlich
auch wieder was anderes.
For the most part it even took a little...
Okay, also, Finger schon mal
im Arsch, wenn man das drunter durchzieht.
...a little chunk out of your bone right here.
But your flesh would most definitely be...
...hanging quick.
Ja, Finger...
Finger ist quasi ab.
...sleep with your hand on the cutting table.
Correct, that happens all the time.
All the time. I'm always getting drowsy
out here.
...sitting there and...
Okay.
Oh, that...
F für den Finger.
Don't be drowsy.
What?
We're gonna do one final
swipe test here across the palm.
Medium fast speed.
Warum haben die ihm das Kam...
die Kamera eigentlich ins Gesicht gehalten jetzt?
Well, it goes through the bones.
Autsch!
It was honestly hard to move once I got it
into here and it ripped its way out.
That's crazy.
Okay, jetzt haben wir schon alles gelernt, was wir in dem Video lernen können.
Deine Hand ist ziemlich im Arsch,
wenn du die da drunter durchgezogen hast.
Den Rest des Videos können wir uns wahrscheinlich sparen.
Ja, so halten sie noch in der Seele.
Die Säge und sonst was.
Also...
Hand ist F.
Hand ist hinüber danach.
Aber damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt auch gerechnet.
Also wie gesagt, ich glaube die Knochen
hinten sind schon auch dran.
Aber...
Der Rest ist...
Aber sowas machst du doch wahrscheinlich
normalerweise mit Handschuhen, oder?
Wir haben einen Notstopp.
Ja, Sägen haben auch teilweise einen Notstopp.
Danach ist aber oftmals das Sägeblatt kaputt.
Also es gibt ja so einen Notstopp
für so...
Wie nennt man das?
Kreissägen?
Die messen irgendwie die Leitfähigkeit
oder die... Irgendwie sowas.
Leitfähigkeit von dem Sägeblatt.
Und wenn du deinen Finger dran hältst,
dann merkt er das quasi in Millisekunden schneller
und haut von unten quasi so einen Bremsblock rein
in das Sägeblatt.
Sodass dein Finger halt noch dran ist.
Selbst wenn du es...
Wenn du es reinhältst.
Dein Finger ist halt dann zumindest
angeschnitten, aber halt nicht ab.
Aber das Sägeblatt ist halt im Arsch.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich? Besser Sägeblatt im Arsch
als Finger ab, oder?
Oh, guys.
Ja.
Sägeblatt ist billiger als Arbeitsunfall.
Der Arbeitsunfall ist ja eh nochmal extra teuer.
Das ist doch 10!
Dann lieber Sägeblatt, oder wie?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
I leaked my IP-Adress.
Oh je, Leute. Jetzt ist vorbei.
Ich habe auch schon meine IP
geleakt.
Instant gehackt
durch den Chat war ich dann wieder.
Chat war instant drin bei mir.
Eure Smart Home
Automation... Ah ja, das gucken wir jetzt.
Das finde ich immer gut.
Also das einzige, was bisher passiert ist,
als ich mal ab und zu meine IP geleakt habe, ist,
dass es irgendwelche komischen DDoS-Leute
nicht lassen konnten und mir den Stream
versauen mussten.
Wobei ich mir dann denke, ja...
Sollen sie mal machen.
Was hältst du von Morpheus Tutorials?
Habe ich tatsächlich erstaunlich wenig gesehen,
aber das, was ich gesehen habe, fand ich nicht schlecht.
Ich habe kaum was gesehen, muss ich sagen, bisher.
Ich kenne den Channel, aber
wenig Content geguckt bisher.
Okay, lassen wir uns mal ein bisschen
Home Automation zeigen wieder.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Oh, eine Tür
Gegensprechanlage. Das ist ja so
meine... Da habe ich ja eine Schwäche für.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Also, ich fange mal wieder eure Automation an
und wo ihr überall Sensoren hingebaut habt.
In Klingeln. Du bist ein Künstler.
Untersitze.
Oder so, dass Stühle wissen können...
NordVPN?
NordVPN gibt es bald.
Ich habe schon eine Anfrage von NordVPN.
Da bald, bald gibt es NordVPN, Leute.
...gestellt sind, damit Sorgroboter
unter Tischen fahren können. Ihr seid echt verrückt.
Also, das Gute verrückt. Auf geht's.
Nicht, dass Putin verrückt. Also lassen wir uns wieder
von euren Automationen inspirieren und ich
lasse für jede gezeigte Automation einen
50 Euro Amazon-Gutschein springen.
Menschentiere-Automation.
Ausgabe 15. Los geht's.
Was ist denn da?
Das ist überhaupt nichts. Fangen wir an mit Tobias.
Der hat ein paar
Frickel-Zeugs-Projekte geschickt.
Ich bin gespannt. Die Frickel-Zeug-Best.
...ist, wie der Name schon sagt, ein Fingerabdruckscanner
und eine Klingel in einem Gerät.
Aha. Da der Auto-Unlock
meines Nukies bei uns nie so richtig zuverlässig
funktioniert hat...
Den Knopf hat er nachträglich reingemacht, oder?
Sieht aber ziemlich gut aus.
Sieht fast original aus.
...wollte ich eine andere Möglichkeit,
um möglichst bequem und schlüssellos
ins Haus zu gelangen. Dazu habe ich
unsere alte Klingelplatte etwas aufgemotzt
und den alten Drucktaster durch einen
runden Finger... Six Head!
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ey, das ist eine
mega nice Idee.
Finger hat man doch immer dabei.
Das muss ich
mir aufschreiben, weil
...
Also, warum ich das sage, ist,
ich bin ja gerade dabei,
dass mein Tor automatisch, mein
Hoftor automatisch auf und zu geht.
Beziehungsweise, nein, nicht automatisch.
Dass ich mein Hoftor elektronisch
auf und zu machen kann.
Wenn du an der Wassersäge bist,
dann ist es die Finger ab.
Chat gute Überleitung zum Video davor.
Oder, was heißt Überleitung?
Retroleitung.
Aber,
das wäre eine coole Sache.
Das wäre eine wirklich coole Sache.
Da brauchst du keine Fernbedienung.
Du brauchst kein
NFC-Tag-Scannen oder sonst was.
Du könntest einfach
deinen Finger dran halten
und
du hättest
die Möglichkeit,
das Hoftor aufzumachen.
Das, finde ich, ist eine richtig
coole Idee.
Du hast gerne ersetzt.
Der hat auf den ersten Blick
den alten Druck,
dass der gar nicht so unendlich sieht
und damit kaum auffällt.
Wird kein Fingerabdruck erkannt,
klingelt wie bisher auch der alte Gong.
Du kannst das für Automation nutzen,
weil du die Finger kennst.
Das ist ja genial.
Das ist wirklich eine coole Idee.
Sprich, wenn einer den Finger drauf hält
und der Knopf erkennt den Finger nicht,
dann klingelt es.
Und wenn du den Finger drauf hältst
und er erkennt den Finger,
dann kannst du zum Beispiel das Hoftor aufmachen.
Das ist eine ziemlich coole Idee.
Sehr nice.
Aber da die Klingel nun noch smart ist,
kann auch Alex ein Wörtchen mitreden
und informiert separat nochmal die Kinder,
die den Gong sonst gerne ignoriert haben.
Wenn nun aber ein Fingerdruck erkannt wurde,
kann ich pro Finger festlegen,
was passieren soll.
So öffnet mein linker Daumen
die Haustür, die rechte die Garage.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Du bist ein Künstler.
Du kannst einfach nur die Finger ausgehen.
Außerdem ist das System so intelligent,
dass Nuki nur angesteuert wird,
wenn du die Finger festlegst.
So ein Video habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Leute, die sich einen NFC,
äh, RFID-Chip
unter die Haut spritzen lassen haben,
dass man
damit dann verschiedene Sachen auslösen kann.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Und es gibt mittlerweile sogar fertiges Sets.
Da ist der RFID-Chip dabei
und so eine Spritze,
um sich das unter die Haut zu spritzen.
Ich würde mir im Leben kein RFID-Chip
unter die Haut spritzen.
Vor allem, wie kriege ich den denn wieder raus,
wenn ich den nicht mehr haben will?
Wenn die Tür auch abgeschlossen ist,
wurde die Tür dazugezogen.
Das ist aber eine richtig gute Idee.
Das gefällt mir.
Das verlängert die Akkuloft-Zeit im Nuki
doch erheblich.
Das Ganze habe ich realisiert
über einen ESP32-Mikrocontroller,
der über MQTT
mit meinem OpenHub-Server verbunden ist.
Ich habe ihn analog über das bereits
alte vorhandene Klingelkabel übertragen,
nur um sicher zu gehen,
dass auch kein Besucher oder Paketbote aufgrund
Okay, lass mal kurz checken.
Also...
Can be used to ring the...
Gut, mit irgendeinem Relay dann,
weil sonst wird das wahrscheinlich nichts.
3, wake up...
input, output...
Ach, das sind die Knöpfe,
die Kabel von dem
von dem Fingerdrucksensor.
Finger detection signal, wake up...
Okay, okay,
das muss man also selbst programmieren,
aber trotzdem ist es eine wirklich gute Idee.
Ich bin am überlegen,
ob ich nicht sowas auch machen sollte.
...und mal streikende Technik unerkannt bleibt.
Den Fall hatte ich anfangs einmal.
Gute Idee, finde ich sehr, sehr nice.
Das sinkt sicherlich sofort
die Akzeptanz in der Familie.
So kam noch eine kleine Web-Anwendung
zur Verwaltung der Fingerabdrücke
und der Konfiguration dazu.
Ich habe aber mittlerweile auch schon zwei Nachbauten
im Freundeskreis. Wer das Ganze
ebenfalls nachbauen möchte,
ich habe den Quellcode und die Binary...
Was ist, wenn einer mit Handschuh kommt?
Naja, musst du halt den Handschuh ausziehen,
wenn du das aufmachen willst.
Aber ich habe nie Handschuhe an, selbst im Winter nicht.
Dokumentation auf Github veröffentlicht.
Du kannst ja immer noch die Fernbedienung drücken
für das Sport.
Ansonsten googelt einfach nach Fingerprint...
Zeig mal her.
Äh...
Fingerprint Doorbell-Projekt.
Ach so,
Paketbote mit Handschuhe kann nicht klingeln,
meint er.
Ne, ne, ne, dafür würde ich es nicht verwenden.
Ich würde die normale Klingel dran lassen
und ich würde zusätzlich das Ding rein zum Öffnen
fürs Tor dran machen, nicht zum Klingeln.
Zum Klingeln, warum sollte ich meine Klingel
auseinander nehmen, die funktioniert ja wunderbar.
Ich würde einfach irgendwie draußen so ein Ding
hinmachen, dass man das auf und zu machen kann,
die Tür.
113 Sterne, äh, 133 Sterne.
Das sieht auch richtig gut aus.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Du siehst fast
nicht den Unterschied
zu dem normalen.
Niedu, dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog.
Pog-Subscription.
Das ist sehr nice, finde ich gut.
Was kostet so ein Teil?
Bei Ali dauert es immer
3-4 Wochen, bis es da ist. Guck mal.
Fingerabdruck...
Sensor.
Nope, nope, nope, nope. Ja, sowas hier.
Wohoho!
Bei AliExpress kostet es wahrscheinlich 3,50.
Importierte China-Chinesen
sind teuer.
Ja, ja, das ist genau das gleiche.
Kostet 5 Euro bei AliExpress oder so.
Alter, was ist mit euch los?
Big Strongs, guck mal mal.
Ähm, warum
wäre das wegen Datenschutz illegal?
Du speicherst ja nicht die Fingerabdrücke
von den Leuten.
Äh...
Fingerprint-Sensor.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Okay, es kostet bei AliExpress schon mal nur die Hälfte.
Aber trotzdem,
warum ist das so teuer?
Keck.
Keck, wait.
Why so teuer?
Dauerhaft.
Das ist typischer China-Import-Name.
Da müsst ihr dann nach Ausschau halten.
Also wenn ihr wissen wollt, ob ein Hersteller China-Chinesen-Import ist,
dann müsst ihr nach solchen
Wörtern Ausschau halten.
Die heißen alle irgendwie
nach so einem speziellen Muster.
Kann ich schwer beurteilen.
Aber die haben alle so einen
Suche im Wörterbuch
random ein Wort raus.
Vorm schöner, schneller
Fingerabdrucksensor.
Ist das Paid-Bewertung?
Arrivato
sceghiato.
Wahrscheinlich heißt das
kam kaputt an?
Kaputt angekommen.
Ja.
Na gut, wenn das bei den Italienern nicht funktioniert.
Aber kaputt ankommen kann er bei mir auch.
Aber 35 Euro ist gerade...
Warum ist das so teuer?
Weshalb ist das Ding so teuer?
Ist doch jetzt nicht so, als wäre da
wahnsinnig
viel Zeug dran.
Professional Performance.
Aber von der Idee
her finde ich das wirklich
sehr, sehr nice.
Alle anderen Sachen sind halt
Müllig.
Aber wenn man sich das hier anguckt.
Nochmal der gleiche.
Der kostet 34 Euro.
Der Kram ist wirklich auf Amazon.de
sehr, sehr teuer.
Ich meine bei AliExpress ist schon teuer.
15 Euro ist für AliExpress ein riesen
Ding. Warum sollte ich dieses Board
Einfach nur ein Spannungswandler, oder?
Ne, was ist das?
Irgendwas mit Buzzer oder so drauf?
Soll ich vielleicht einen Scanner suchen?
Naja, ne. Ganz schön teuer.
Für so ein kleines Teil.
Aber ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Ich glaube, das werde ich mir mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
Ah ja, gut.
Ein Klo braucht man ja auch.
Einen Fingerabdrucksensor braucht man nicht wirklich.
Das ist reine Spielerei.
Und im Vergleich dazu benutzt du das Klo halt auch
für wichtige Geschäfte.
Natürlich ist ein Klo wichtiger als
ein Fingerabdrucksensor.
Wie das Projekt und zu den ganzen Produkten,
soweit ich die finden kann, die wir heute im Video sehen,
unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Mein zweites Projekt, das ich euch vorstellen möchte,
ist das NS Panel von Sonoff.
Ja, das juckt mich überhaupt nicht, das Ding.
Da gibt es ja mittlerweile ein neues NS Panel
sogar mit Android drauf.
Da habe ich kein Anwendungsgebiet für.
Also im Flur habe ich meine
Fire HD 10 Dashboards hängen,
die besser sind als jedes Sonoff Panel.
Vor allem haben sie mehr Platz.
Ganz normales Home Assistant Dashboard drauf.
Das Panel habe ich direkt am ersten Tag
mit Tasmota geflasht
und dann meine eigene
Ah, das ist noch das alte
ESP32 NS Panel.
Das ist ja noch unsinniger.
Hier zeige ich mir an der Haustür
die wichtigsten Infos an,
die ich bei Betreten des Hauses benötige,
neben der gefühlten Außentemperatur.
Ganz ehrlich, ich gucke morgen Wetterbericht
und gut ist und außerdem kann ich auf mein Tablet
im Flur gucken.
Ja, sieht jetzt sehr brauchbar aus und je nachdem,
wie wir das gemacht haben,
habe ich keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Das habe ich übrigens auch, also die Anzeigen
habe ich mehr oder weniger genauso bei mir auf dem Tablet.
Ich habe eine Anzeige, ob noch Licht an ist.
Ich habe eine Anzeige, ob noch Fenster
oder Türkontakte offen sind.
Gut, Garage habe ich nicht drin,
weil Garage ist nicht automatisch öffnenbar.
Und Alarmanlage,
ja,
ob ein Fenster offen ist
oder ob die Garage noch offen ist
oder der Status der Alarmanlage.
Ich frage mich, wie du mit dem Schauen aus dem Fenster
sagen willst, wie der Vormittag insgesamt wird.
Ich meine, du kannst sagen, jetzt scheint die Sonne,
aber du weißt ja nicht unbedingt,
wie das um 12 Uhr heute Mittag ist.
... dass ich mir über ein kleines Textfeld
zum Beispiel die gesamte Liste der noch offenen Fenster.
Über die Symbole kann ich zudem Lichter
oder Rolllänen pro Stockwerk schalten
oder auch die Garage öffnen und schließen.
Für die Haustür nutze ich einen eigenen Fensterkontakt.
Damit ist Nuki auch hier
... Da hat er sich aber Mühe gegeben.
Was ist das für ein Kontakt?
Kleiner Exkurs zu Fenster- und Türkontakten.
Ich nutze mittlerweile überall die Fensterkontakte FT.
Ah, das ist Dings hier.
Das ist N-Ocean, glaube ich.
Also das ist so ein
Funkprotokoll,
wo die Sensoren keine Batterien
benötigen.
Ja, kostet was,
aber dafür musst du nie Batterien tauschen.
Die machen das irgendwie so,
das ist irgendwie so ein ultra low power Funkprotokoll
und durch quasi die Energie,
die das Schalten irgendwie bringt,
können die einmalig übertragen.
Du musst halt nie Batterien tauschen.
Es hat was, ja.
Aber es ist halt teuer.
Ganz ehrlich, in dem Fall kaufe ich
Reichweite musst du mal gucken.
N-Ocean heißt der Kram, glaube.
Aber
ganz im Ernst,
die ganzen passiven Sensoren,
sei es jetzt Fenster-Tür-Kontakte
oder auch Schalter, die halten
Jahre, die halten wirklich lang
mit kleinen Batterien drin.
...EKE von El Taco.
Die sind zwar mit 45 Euro recht teuer,
lassen sich aber unsichtbar im Fensterrahmen
verstecken und dank N-Ocean
und Energy Harvesting nie wieder
eine Batterie wechseln zu müssen, war für mich
schlichtweg das Killer-Feature überhaupt.
Vollständigkeit halber will ich auch noch kurz
meinen automatisierten Briefkasten zeigen.
Das funktioniert bei mir leider nicht richtig.
Das ist auch ein Projekt, was noch ansteht.
Briefkasten.
Aber mein Briefkasten hat so eine
komische Form.
Da habe ich ja nichts Gutes gefunden.
... hat ja gefühlt jeder mittlerweile ein.
Nee, ich nicht.
Ich habe viel Automatisierungs-Shit,
aber keinen Briefkasten.
... einen optischen Sensor montiert,
damit ich sowohl mitbekomme, wenn neue Post eingeworfen
und auch von uns wieder entnommen wird.
Bei neuer Post gibt es eine Durchsage
von Alexa und auch eine Benachrichtigung aufs Handy.
Zudem zeige ich auch
auf dem NS-Panel statt des Wetters
die neue Post.
Also eigentlich hätte er dafür das hier nehmen müssen.
Sie haben Post.
Eigentlich hätte er das nehmen müssen, oder?
Falls das noch irgendjemand kennt.
Da Frauen Kinder
der Technik nicht immer trauen
oder im Falle der Kinder mich manchmal einfach nur ärgern wollen,
kann ich den Status am NS-Panel
auch noch manuell quittieren.
Am nächsten Projekt bist du schuld.
Oder besser gesagt einer deiner Zuschauer.
Er hat mit seiner Vorstellung von Autositzsensoren
mir völlig neue Welten eröffnet.
What?
Moment, Moment.
Was?
Ist das
Gewichtssensor
auf dem Stuhl?
Six Head Time, Alter!
Da kann man erkennen,
wenn man auf dem Stuhl sitzt.
Bis wie viel Kilo ist das belastbar?
Aber das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Da kann man was mit anfangen.
Von Autositzsensoren
mir völlig neue Welten eröffnet.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie ich bisher ohne ein automatisiertes Bett
überhaupt leben konnte.
Leider funktionieren die Autositzsensoren
unter einer 15 cm dicken Matratze nicht wirklich gut.
Also habe ich nach einer anderen Lösung gesucht
und auch gefunden.
Bei mir sind nun unter den beiden Lappenrosten
jeweils vier Wägezellen
im 3D gedruckten Gehäuse
zusammen mit einem ESP.
Damit habe ich tatsächlich auch mal
experimentiert.
Ich hatte es zum Beispiel so,
dass es dann Licht ausgeschaltet hat
15 Minuten nachdem ich ins Bett bin.
Coole Sache, aber eigentlich
relativ überflüssige Spielerei.
Mikrocontroller
Man kann auch,
wenn man wirklich erkennen will,
ob man im Bett ist,
auch ganz gut funktionieren kann.
Man kann zum Beispiel,
wenn man sein Handy abends anschließt
und lädt, falls man das macht,
kann man das machen.
Oder meistens geht es auch mit Uhrzeit ganz gut.
Oder aber,
so wie ich es mittlerweile habe,
ich habe einfach bei mir an der Tür
jetzt einen Schalter hängen,
da drücke ich drauf für ich gehe ins Bett.
Und dann weiß ich auch sicher,
dann ist es keine Zufallserkennung oder so.
Dann weiß ich auch sicher,
dass ich das nicht machen kann.
Und was passiert denn eigentlich noch?
Lichter ausschalten?
Spaß eigentlich.
Überall
Lichter ausschalten.
Das Motor als Firmware im Einsatz.
Ach so, ja.
Und das Licht im Schlafzimmer noch anlassen.
Und so was.
Und dann das Licht dann im Schlafzimmer
automatisch ausschalten nach einer Minute.
Da kann man schon ganz coole Sachen machen.
Das sieht aber so ein bisschen so aus,
wie wenn man sich in der Nacht
auf die andere Betthälfte gewogen hat.
Dünnes Eis.
Das gesamte Ehebett ist nun
eine einzige große Waage
mit zwei voneinander unabhängigen Waagschalen.
Und damit lässt sich
Ob die Frau so gerne gewogen wird?
dann recht gut arbeiten.
Und nicht nur eine Belegungserkennung realisieren,
die zum Beispiel eine Zu-Bett-Geh-Routine
oder Aufsteh-Routine triggert,
sondern abhängig vom Gewicht
oder auch Zusatzgewicht zu gewissen Zeiten
auch andere nette Spielereien treiben.
Was passiert denn, wenn das Gewicht
in kurzer Zeit sich ändert?
Das ist Mamas und Papas Bett.
Geh wieder zurück in deins.
Gute Nacht.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Also bei uns hilft so eine Ansage im Moment
egal, ob sie von Alexa oder von mir kommt,
nicht so richtig.
Darum trage ich diese Augenringe.
Ja, danke Tobias.
Ich sehe keine Augenringe.
Mein Kopf brummt ein bisschen.
Die Klingel mit dem Fingerabdruck ist genial.
Und das Wiegebett ist auch
auf jeden Fall eine interessante Idee.
Auch der ganze Rest.
Mit dem NS-Panel habe ich nach wie vor
noch ein kleines Namensproblem.
Stimmt, das hat wirklich einen blöden Namen.
Gerade in Deutschland.
Und einfach die verschiedenen Sachen.
Ich glaube, du hattest Home-Matic-Sensoren,
den El-Taco-Fenster-Sensor,
also einfach alles so zusammengezogen,
wie es für dich gut funktioniert.
Die Türklingel-Geschichte ist wirklich nice.
Und wenn auch ihr was zu zeigen habt,
dann schickt es gerne
in die Kommentare.
Also, sendet bitte nicht unbedingt
ein 6-Minuten-Video wie Tobias ein.
Eure Chancen stehen besser
und euer Lohn ist auch besser,
wenn es nur 2-3 Minuten lang ist.
Und wie gesagt,
für jede gezeigte Aufnahme
gibt es 50 Euro.
Und diese 50 Euro bekommt auch Michael,
falls sein Video es in den finalen
Schnitt des Videos schafft.
Eine Automatisierung, um das Staubsaugen
mit meinem Roborock-Staubsauger
so einfach und...
... wie möglich zu gestalten.
In der Küche wird hierbei nur benötigt,
dass nach dem Essen der Tisch abgeräumt
und abgewischt wird.
Danach werden die Stühle hochgestellt
und die Küche einfach verlassen.
Kurz darauf wird die Küche
automatisch gestaubt.
Guck mal, der hat da unten irgendwas dran.
Ist das... Ist das ein Sensor,
der erkennt, ob das Ding auf dem Kopf
steht oder nicht?
Irgendein... Irgendein...
Beschleunigungssensor oder
irgendwas in der Richtung?
So ist...
Gut, das passiert bei uns auch über
eine Zeitschaltfunktion. Du hast jetzt gesagt,
das hängt an Arbeitsabläufen.
Ich habe nicht gesehen, dass
irgendjemand bei euch gerade
irgendwas...
Wie weiß denn der Tisch, dass er abgewischt ist?
Ja, da ist ja irgendwas unten... Irgendwas ist
da unten am Stuhl dran.
Die Automatisierung dazu habe ich
in Habitat mit Regeln...
Habitat? Verwendet das jemand? Okay.
Küche-Chairs-Up-Sensor?
Was ist das?
Hexerei?
Ah, okay.
Das ist das Weiße, was man da unten sieht.
Und was hat er da dran?
Ach so!
Alter, das ist ja viel simpler, als ich das gedacht
habe. Das ist ja viel simpler,
als ich gedacht habe. Ich dachte, da hat er irgendeinen
Beschleunigungssensor oder sowas dran.
Der hat einfach so einen ganz normalen Fenster
Open-Close-Sensor.
Und den hat er in so ein
Gehäuse gesteckt, dass der Sensor sich halt
bewegen kann. Der Sensor geht nach unten,
wenn der Kopf übersteht.
Beziehungsweise, ne. Der Sensor geht nach unten,
wenn der normal steht.
Und der Sensor geht ran, wenn der
rumgedreht wird. Das ist eigentlich
ziemlich High-IQ.
Also aus
was simplem, was
Six-Headiges gemacht. Genau.
Six-Head-Move mit
Three-Head-Technik. So sieht's aus.
Was das daneben ist, weiß ich nicht so genau.
Das ist ja genial.
High-IQ.
Ihr seid ja in Best-Form.
Das brauch ich auf jeden Fall noch.
Ist der Türkontakt offen,
so ist der Stuhl hingestellt und wird
benutzt. Das heißt intern,
dass der Status der Küche auf
schmutzig gestellt wird.
Werden nun die Stühle wieder alle hochgestellt,
schließt sich der Türkontakt-Sensor.
Eine Automatisierung
prüft dann, ob...
Das sieht aus wie so ein ganz normaler
Aqara
Xiaomi
Türkontakt-Sensor.
Hat der
das 3D-Model irgendwo?
...ob alle Stühle hochgestellt
sind und sich der Zustand
der Küche auf schmutzig befindet und
natürlich, dass auch die Küchentür
geschlossen wurde.
Dann fährt er los.
Das ist
ein einfacher Fensterkontakt.
Ja, die Idee ist gut.
...Sigbee-Schalter installiert.
Das Betätigen eines Schalters fügt
die ID des Raumes über eine
Node-RED-Automatisierung zu einer
Liste hinzu. Gleichzeitig wird
immer ein einminütiger Timer angestoßen
beziehungsweise zurückgesetzt.
Nach Ablauf des Timers
wird diese Liste an Räumen
dann an Roborock übergeben.
Und somit werden diese Räume dann
gestaubsaugt. So ist es ein Kinderspiel
für Frauen und Kinder, jederzeit in
jedem Raum das Staubsaugen
anzustoßen, ohne sich auch nur
einmal mit der App auseinanderzusetzen.
Aber eine gute Idee ist es so, nach dem Motto
drauf und beim nächsten Durchgang fährt er
dann in den Raum. Eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Also das baue ich auf jeden Fall nach. Einfach
ein billiger Fensterkontakt, der in einer
kleinen Führungsschiene, die ich selber
drucken kann, rumrutscht. Wunderbar.
Danke, Michael. Ja, gute Idee.
Ich denke, da könnten wir tatsächlich
den ein oder anderen Nachahmer anstiften.
Also mindestens einen. So, Johannes sichert
Daten mit Kurzbefehlen am Mac. Wirklich gute Idee.
Das klingt für mich wie ein Rezept
für Desaster. Schauen wir mal rein,
was er sich da gebastelt hat.
Ich habe mir eine kleine Automation gebaut
und das Schreiben meiner Bachelorarbeit
ein bisschen zuerst.
Was sehen wir da im Hintergrund?
Was ist das? Ist das HomeKit?
Nee, Shortcuts ist das.
Apple Siri Shortcuts.
Das ist Paintschamp
zu arbeiten damit, Alter. Selbst einfache
Sachen sind da fünf Seiten lang.
Das Programm ist teilweise nicht sehr
zuverlässig in der Speicherung
von Daten. Außerdem kommt es manchmal
vor, dass ich Änderungen vornehme,
die ich am Ende gerne rückgängig
gemacht hätte. Dann ist aber
schon einige Zeit vergangen
und mir fällt die Textpassage zum Beispiel
nicht mehr ein.
Wie wäre es, er könnte es einfach in Plaintext
schreiben und in Git einchecken?
Diesen Umstand zu lösen und um
eine Sicherung zu haben, habe ich mir
in der Kurzbefehle-App eine kleine
Automation gebaut, die genau
das löst. Und dazu
ruft er am Anfang den Netzwerknamen
von meinem WLAN ab, mit dem mein Mac
gerade verbunden ist. Das hat den Hintergrund,
dass... Chat sehe ich genauso.
Wenn er die Probleme nicht...
...zusätzlich auf meinem
Heim-Server speichern möchte,
wenn das Netzwerk einen beliebigen
Wert hat, also immer wenn ich mit einem Netzwerk
verbunden bin, erstellt er
hier aus dem Dokumente-Ordner...
Ah, das interessiert mich nicht. Next.
...gesucht oder so. Mein Mail-Programm
macht in der aktuellen Version
von irgendwelchen Arbeiten, aber generell
Short-Reel hatte ich nicht auf dem Zettel.
Hm. Shortcut-Trigger,
Application, Time...
Das ist sogar in der Gratis-Version.
Das ist ein Traum. Vielen Dank
für diesen Hinweis. Und alles
Gute für die Bachelor-Arbeit. Aber jetzt kommen wir zu
einer ganz anderen Automation von mir. Jede Woche
öffnet sich... Ah, Sponsor.
...diese App und ich kann aus über 30
wechselnden Rezepten rausgehen. Nice, nice Sponsoring.
Und dann kommt ein paar Tage
später hier ein Karton mit abgezählten
Zutaten und schicken
Rezeptkarten nach Hause. Ich muss
mir keine Gedanken machen, was es zu Essen
oder zu Thermomix oder extra dabei ist,
die du sonst, wenn du für dich selbst gekocht hättest,
vielleicht weggelassen hättest.
Den Link unten in der Videobeschreibung benutzen.
Frohes Automatisieren und guten Appetit.
Apropos Essen.
Pit liefert ein paar Kühe
für die Tiere im Namen dieses Formats.
Also mit Apropos Essen meine ich,
dass es hier irgendwie um ein smartes Fressgitter
geht. Nicht um die Tiere natürlich.
Vom Herdenmanagement-Programm
beim Mechanismus.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung von Viehzucht.
What?
Ich checke überhaupt nicht, was da
passiert. Wolle, dankeschön für 15
Monate Subscription. Was bin ich
sehend?
Fünfeinhalb
Wegeventil.
Damit kann man
irgendwie Gitter auf und zu machen oder so?
Und was passiert jetzt?
Die kriegt den Hals abgeschnitten oder wie?
Die allerdings auch nicht.
Ich hoffe ja nicht.
Ach, jetzt sind sie eingefangen. Jetzt kommen sie nicht mehr raus.
Ne.
Hä?
Okay, um 4.30 Uhr
werden die Fressgitter.
Geschaltet.
Ich muss gestehen, ich habe nicht so richtig verstanden, was hier passiert.
Ich auch nicht. Ich auch nicht.
Um die Tiere fixieren,
um an den Tieren arbeiten zu können. Fieber messen.
Trächtigkeitsuntersuchung.
Ach, da geht das Gitter zu, dass
der Kopf da drin stecken bleibt oder wie?
Und das Warten, bis die Kühe eingefangen haben, war nicht smart genug.
Die Kühe werden nach dem Melken am
Melkroboter automatisch aussortiert in die
Behandlungsbox.
Und das Ganze mit Pneumatik gelöst,
weil die Melkroboter Druckluft benötigen.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Okay, es gibt Fressen.
Dadurch, dass es Fressen gibt,
strecken die Kühe ihren Hals durch das Gitter.
Dann geht das Gitter zu,
sodass man an die Kühe dran kann.
Aha, verstehe.
Behandeln und vermeiden Kriegsstörungen.
Ja, ganz spannend.
Also, dass man sowas einfach mit ein paar
Zwischensteckern auf die Melke macht.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein paar Landwirte unter euch,
die aus dieser Geschichte
irgendwie ein bisschen was gewinnen können.
Oh, da sind ein paar Landwirte unter euch.
Die andere Automation
für zukünftige Ausgaben für mich haben.
So, Alwin berichtet von KNX
und da habe ich doch im Moment
ein sehr
gespitztes, offenes Ohr,
weil das ja eine Option für das neue Haus ist.
Und wenn ihr dieses Video seht,
dann bin ich fast aus dem Urlaub zurück
und dann können wir endlich mit Livestreams
rund um das neue Haus anfangen.
Vielleicht ist der auch schon geplant
und du findest den unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Aber jetzt schauen wir erstmal, was Alwin geschickt hat.
Und zwar habe ich in meinem Haus
ein KNX-System verbaut,
was aber leider nicht ganz vollständig war,
da ich alles selbst geplant und mir alles selbst
beigebracht habe.
Dazu später aber mehr.
Um diese Automation zu realisieren,
habe ich mich für Apple HomeKit entschieden
und habe mir dieses kleine Gerät hier gekauft,
das mein KNX-System
HomeKit-fähig macht.
Mit Hilfe dieses Geräts kann ich...
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich mag HomeKit nicht sonderlich.
Interaktion mit
Apple-Geräten ist natürlich nice.
Wenn man das unbedingt
dort dann beispielsweise
im Widget haben will oder so.
Aber ansonsten kommt man auch wunderbar
ohne HomeKit aus.
Alle meine Geräte in HomeKit steuern
und natürlich dann auch entsprechende
Automationen erstellen.
Zumal Apple wieder ganz komische Geschichten macht.
Du konntest die ganze Zeit
ein am Kabel hängendes
iPad als HomeKit
Hub oder so verwenden.
Also sprich, dass du auch
von außen schalten kannst und so, wenn man das will.
Das geht nicht mehr.
Hat Apple jetzt abgeschafft
und es geht jetzt nur noch mit einem Apple TV
oder einem Apple HomeKit Hub
oder sowas.
Solange ich einen Bogen
um HomeKit machen kann und es nicht für irgendwas
braucht, mache ich einen großen Bogen drum.
Habe ich auch hier schon angefangen.
Und zwar gehen dann
zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit im ganzen
Erdgeschoss
die Rollladen runter,
die Beleuchtung am Haus sowie der Springbrunnen an.
Der Springbrunnen?
Ja, da sind auch diverse Geräte im Haus.
Diese Automation habe ich
wie gesagt ohne großen Aufwand
in Apple HomeKit erstellt.
Ich will noch eine weitere Automation,
dass um 0.30 Uhr
dann die ganze Beleuchtung im Haus
und am Haus ausgeschaltet wird.
So wie alle Steckdosen und anderen Geräte,
die nachts nichts zu tun haben sollten.
Da habe ich mich übrigens auch von dir
inspirieren lassen,
als du mal darüber berichtet hattest,
dass deine Klimaanlage die ganze Nacht gelaufen ist.
Ich erinnere mich.
Also grundsätzlich eine Automation zu haben,
die irgendwie nachts einmal
alles sicherheitshalber abfällt,
kann in Zeiten,
wo wir noch ein bisschen genauer auf Energieverbräuche
gucken, schon ganz wertvoll sein.
Ja, und um nochmal auf den Anfang
zu sprechen zu kommen.
Ja, er hört sich mit seinem KNX-System so ein bisschen gelangweilt an.
So fehlen mir ja hier im System
auch viele Komponenten, die ein Haus
erst wirklich smart machen.
Jetzt wollen wir mal sehen, was ihm fehlt,
weil das ist ja der spannende Teil.
Die Reue eines Hobby-KNX-Implementeurs.
Wie zum Beispiel
Tür- oder Fensterkontakte,
eine Wetterstation, einen Zeitserver
und so weiter.
Wetterstation habe ich ja mittlerweile.
Haben wir ja sogar im Stream mal ein bisschen was gebastelt für.
Wetterstation habe ich und muss sagen,
ich bin echt zufrieden damit,
weil
jetzt zum ersten Mal habe ich wirklich
ordentliche Außentemperatur,
wo ich auch weiß, das stimmt halbwegs.
Also sowohl Außentemperatur
als eben auch Windgeschwindigkeit.
Und ob es geregnet hat
in letzter Zeit. So diese drei Sachen.
Das ist eigentlich das, was mich hauptsächlich interessiert.
Hat es geregnet so die letzten 1-2 Stunden?
Ist viel Wind?
Beziehungsweise welche Temperatur?
Der Rest interessiert mich jetzt nicht so sehr,
was die Wetterstation auch kann.
Aber das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Also es hat sich gelohnt, die China-Chinesen-Wetterstation
da hinzustellen.
Zeitserver?
Ich wusste nicht mal, dass das eine Sache ist.
Gar nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da vermissen könnte.
Ohne NTP lokal,
wie sollen deine Geräte denn die richtige Zeit haben?
Dauerhaft.
Vielen Dank für den Input, Alwin.
Also mich hat es auf jeden Fall interessiert.
Ich hoffe einige von euch auch.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal weiter.
Tobias hatte irgendwas mit Rudern geschickt.
Was ist das da hinten?
Ist das ein Reiskocher?
Popcorn-Maschine?
Einmal wenn es dunkel ist,
dass es dann halt das Licht angeht.
Und zum anderen, wenn ein bisschen coole Musik läuft.
Und das habe ich relativ einfach hier
mit meinem Rudergerät gemacht.
Kann man aber auch mit sämtlichen anderen Geräten machen.
Ah, ein Widerstand fürs Rudern, okay.
Da könnte ich vielleicht schon denken.
Ich habe hier einen Motion-Sensor drinnen oder drunter.
Ich kann das mal zeigen.
Seht ihr hier.
Unter dem Sitz.
Und wenn man anfängt zu rudern,
dann bewegt er sich.
Und dadurch wird eine Bewegung erkannt.
Es ist aber auch so, dass eine gewisse...
Da geht aber die Batterie relativ schnell leer,
weil er Bewegung erkennt.
...Pufferzone drin ist.
Tobias, ich möchte deine Träume nicht zerstören,
aber das, was du da machst, ist kein Rudern.
Aber die Batterie geht schnell.
Aha.
Also wenn man hier, ich glaube 30 Sekunden ist es,
wenn man anfängt zu rudern.
Dann wird...
Im Moment läuft auch Radio im Hintergrund.
Dann merkt er sich das, dass vorher Radio lief.
Da ist das Licht angegangen, hier oben.
Aha.
Und die Musik.
Boah.
Toss. Toss. Toss.
Ich nehme euch das mal kurz weg.
Toss, ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Und wenn ich aufhöre zu rudern...
Toss. Toss. Mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Ausschalten geht auf jeden Fall schnell.
Und die Musik ist auch wieder...
Das Ding wird total schnell die Batterie verlieren,
weil der Pau permanent Motion meldet.
Da ist es wahrscheinlich in
zwei, drei Monaten ist es leer.
Das Ding.
Jetzt läuft das Radio schon wieder.
Das heißt, er stellt den ursprünglichen Zustand wieder her.
Auch ganz nett.
Allerdings sind natürlich die ersten 30 Sekunden,
die du dann im Winter im Zweifel im Dunkeln
und ohne Musik ruderst, etwas trostlos.
Aber das kann ja auch ein
Ansporn für den Sport sein.
Eigentlich wäre es besser,
die Sicherheitsphase irgendwie an
die Anzahl der Ruderbewegungen
zu binden.
Wenn ich jetzt einfach schnell durchziehe,
dann kriege ich schnell Licht an.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Rudern.
Willis Video fängt offenbar mit mir an.
Das kann ja kein gutes Zeichen sein.
Dir die Möglichkeit erlaubt,
auch Sachen zu steuern.
Gut, die Fenster wirst du jetzt nicht
per Knopfdruck zu machen können.
An diesem Punkt muss ich dich gleich einmal unterbrechen.
Anzeige ist raus.
Okay.
Hey Siri.
Was hat denn hier alles am Start?
Schalte Fenster aus.
Boah, ist das laut.
Die Idee dazu kam mir, da meine Schwester
im Zimmer unter mir wohnt.
The fuck?
Was für ein riesen Ding, Mann.
... vom Balkon raucht.
Dadurch zieht der Rauch immer zu mir ins Zimmer.
Was besonders, wenn man gerade durchlüften will,
durchaus störend ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das als Korrektur
für meine Aussage akzeptieren kann.
Also ja, technisch schließen deine Fenster automatisch.
Aber es gibt da so zwei
kleine Haken an der Sache.
Vielleicht finden die anderen Zuschauer einen.
Das Ding hängt halb im Raum.
Diese Lösung nimmt natürlich viel Platz in den Ecken weg.
Vor allem wenn es verweht, so finden sie es auf jeden Fall.
Aber da ich diese Ecken sowieso
nur als Abstellfläche nutze,
sind die Motoren nicht allzu sehr im Weg.
Gesteuert wird das Ganze über ein Relaisboard
aus einer Steckdosenleiste von Diele Smart Home.
Okay.
... die letztendlich mit HomeKit kompatibel ist.
Dieses Board habe ich ausgebaut
und mit 5 Volt versorgt.
Die zwei Relais auf dem Board
steuern je ein weiteres Relais pro Fenster an,
welches den Strom der Linearmotoren um...
Ist das...
Ich hoffe nicht, dass hier irgendwie 230 Volt rumläuft, oder?
Das ist dann vielleicht doch ein bisschen...
...
... etwas mutig?
... am Fenstergriff befindet sich ein Schalter,
der bei geschlossenem Griff den Strom flucht...
Ist das ein Legostein?
Ist das ein tragender Legostein?
...
Hey Siri, schalte Fenster ein.
Schalte Fenster ein!
Boah, ist das laut auch!
öffnen also ist eine coole sache aber ganz im ernst ich also ich hätte das nicht gebaut wenn
wir da nix bisschen schöneres eingefallen wäre in und außen temperatur und feuchtigkeit sensoren
verbauen um ein automatisiertes lüften zu ermöglichen wenn beispielsweise nach einem
warmen tag denn da oben an der decke und so alles hängen zudem arbeite ich gerade noch an
einer möglichkeit die rollos zu automatisieren was allerdings noch etwas software braucht
damit das fenster nicht geöffnet werden kann solange die rollos unten sind okay also ich
finde auf jeden fall gut dass du etwas gebaut hast das ist ja irgendwie die hauptsache an der ganzen
geschichte also nicht wie macht cooles bastelding aber also ich hätte weiß ich lege jetzt ja nicht
so wahnsinnig viel wert darauf dass das alles komplett unsichtbar ist und und alles super
gestylt ist aber das wäre mir auch zu hart gewesen der lösung ist weil die meisten leute die ich
kenne so ein bisschen an ihrem wohnort
umhängen aber was auch immer für dich funktioniert ist für dich das richtige
leon hat ein ikea icon generator gebaut schauen wir mal rein hallo andreas heute zeige ich dir
meinen simplen ikea tradzi icon generator die bedienung ist eigentlich ziemlich selbsterklärend
als erstes wählt man ein für sich passendes icon aus der gefühlt nicht enden wollenden
auswahlliste aus und dann anschließend skaliert man das icon bis es einem gefällt und gut aussieht aber aber warum warum braucht man das icon
dass mail ab dazu einen kurs durch den pdf klicken und den aufkloppten dialog bestätigen jetzt müssen wir nur noch kurz warten ja dann haben wir pdf dass wir ausdrucken können mit unserem gewünschten
und dann fertig aus 8 zum draufkleben dass dann so aus es ist auf jeden fall noch verbesserung bedarf
vorhanden bei dem Projekt zum Beispiel, dass eine komplette Seite ausgefüllt wird beim Drucken. Da setze ich mich wahrscheinlich immer mal dran, wenn ich mehr Zeit dafür habe.
Coole Leute hätten dafür jetzt irgendein Laser-Gravur-System. Aber sowas habe ich nicht und sowas will ich auch nicht.
Auch sehr nett. Also mehr als ein gleiches Icon auf einer Seite wäre natürlich auch noch ganz nett.
Aber wenn ihr Verwendung dafür habt und euch irgendwie Icons für eure Ikea-Shortcut-Buttons zusammenbasteln wollt,
ich habe auch den Generator unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt.
Genauso den Link, um eure Automationen und Inspirationen einzusenden mit der Chance auf einen Amazon-Gutschein,
mit dem ihr euch dann gerne noch mehr Spielzeug für noch mehr Automationen, die ihr dann wieder einsenden könnt, kaufen könnt.
Danke allen Einsendern und dir ganz cool fürs Zuschauen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich muss sagen, die Klingel, also generell die Idee, einen Fingerabdrucksensor draußen hinzumachen, finde ich super.
Gerade für mein Hoftor zum automatisch auf- und zumachen.
Da könnte ich mir tatsächlich...
Da könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass ich sowas machen werde.
Aber erstmal muss ich mein Hoftor fertig elektronisch auf- und zufahrbar machen.
Steuerung und so ist ja alles fertig, auch mit dem ESP32 drin.
Aber auf der einen Seite ist halt der Motor noch nicht dran.
So sieht's aus.
Machen wir das mal zu alles.
Ach ja, was machen eigentlich die Battlefield-Spielerzahlen?
Die sind gerade dabei sind. Okay, die sind wieder abgekackt, alles klar.
Was macht, was macht New World?
Okay, es ist tatsächlich wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen.
Wahnsinn.
Okay.
Gasper, YouTube ein Redesign.
Ja.
Es ist jetzt alles rund.
Da haben irgendein Ex-Apple-Designer wahrscheinlich mit...
... ein bisschen karg.
Klar, da sind viele Details auf den Rüstungen von Kratos jetzt zu sehen.
... und...
Ich bin echt mal gespannt drauf.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich eine Playstation nur dafür kaufe.
Ganz im Ernst.
Wahrscheinlich warte ich echt, bis es auf PC kommt.
Oder ich gucke mir mal wirklich wieder ein Let's Play an, was ich ja eigentlich so gut wie kaum noch mache.
Hast du schon das neue Video...
... äh, was?
iPhone Lightning.
Nee.
Ist mir jetzt auch zu harte Kost.
Leute, wisst ihr was wirklich sehr, sehr unpraktisch gerade ist?
Es ist...
10 Uhr und ich krieg schon Hunger langsam.
Normalerweise
wäre 11.
Und
ja,
naja, machst du nix.
Is coding really dead?
Okay, komm, wir gucken uns eine Runde Fireship an.
Fireship ist immer pock.
Coding is dead.
I've seen this prediction thrown around more and more lately.
Ah, ist alles, alles blödsinnig.
Das ist nicht dead.
It's in my best interest
to shill for the learn to code industry
on this channel. However, looking into
2023, there are some really bad looking
storm clouds on the horizon. In today's video
we'll look at six messed up trends that
might kill programming once and for all.
Along with a few shreds of hope at the end.
Before we get into it, I'd recommend you sign up for
Fireship Pro to learn how to code with a
brand new platform I built from scratch that
provides an addictive, meme-driven experience.
And this might be your last chance to support the channel
before coding dies forever.
The first trend I want to talk about is stalled technology.
Now, normally I love making fun of Facebook
on this channel, but things have gotten so bad
with the Metaverse that I honestly just
Is Facebook eigentlich immer noch PHP?
feel sad at this point. Like, the entire Metaverse
likely has fewer daily active users
than that shitty side project that you totally forgot about.
Where are you going?
Was, was passiert?
Like, they just keep pouring money into this thing
and so far it's been nothing but an embarrassing flop.
I'd highly recommend watching this video
from Mental Outlaw to learn more about why it sucks so bad.
Now, even though the Metaverse sucks right now,
Ich hab's ja schon mehrfach gesagt, dass ja so
gar die Entwickler, die Metawerber,
dass Entwickler keinen Bock auf diesen Scheiß haben
und sich fragen, warum machen sie das eigentlich.
Und im Prinzip sind sie jetzt auf dem gleichen Stand wie ich.
Sie machen das, weil es Geld gibt.
Der Rest geht ihnen am Arsch vorbei.
Das bedeutet nicht, dass es in der Zukunft
nicht eine große Sache sein wird.
Es gibt viele Technologien, die nicht vollständig
auf dem Punkt sind, wo es eine große Anforderung
für neue Programmer gibt, aber die Potenzial
für die Zukunft groß sind, wie
selbstmachende Autos, 3D-Printing,
Quantencomputing und Augmented Reality.
Diese Technologien sind groß, aber sie haben nicht
ihr volles Potenzial erreicht, wie ein Smartphone.
Und die große Frage ist, werden sie ever get there?
In meiner Meinung nach, die Adoption
dieser Technologien ist bis jetzt ziemlich
bescheuert. Wenn sie nicht vollständig
auf dem Punkt sind, bedeutet das, dass es viele
tote Programmer gibt, die nicht auf dem Punkt sind.
Der nächste Trend, der literally jeden
Menschen auf der Welt beeinflusst, ist der
aktuelle ökonomische Zerfall.
Ökonomisten haben keine Ahnung,
wie die Inflation so hoch ist.
Aber deswegen sterben ja Programmierer nicht aus.
Es hat definitiv nichts mit all dem Geld zu tun,
das in den letzten 10 Jahren geprintet wurde.
Um ehrlich zu sein, sind auch Nobelpreis-Winner-Ökonomisten
nicht sehr gut, Prediktionen zu machen.
Wie 1998, als Paul Krugman dachte,
dass die Internet keine größere Impaktion als eine Fax-Maschine hätte.
Jetzt, dass Auskunftsinflation eine Realität ist,
sind Zentralbanken Interessensrate erhöht.
Und das ist ein großes Problem für Programmierer.
Die große Mehrheit von Start-ups und viele
öffentlich geteilte Unternehmen machen keine Geld.
Sie operieren in der Red und verlangen Investoren,
um ihre Lohnkosten zu verkaufen.
Bis sie profitabler werden oder verkauft werden.
Oder sie gehen aus dem Geschäft.
Höhere Interessensrate machen es viel schwieriger,
Venture-Kapitalisten für diese Start-ups easy Geld zu bieten.
Und das bedeutet, dass Start-ups, die Geld verdienen,
viel mehr vorsichtig sind, wie sie es verdienen.
Und eines der größten Kosten für eine Start-up
sind Programmierer.
Bis heute scheint der Job-Markt
auf einem Makro-Level sehr stark zu sein.
Aber letzte Woche gab es Läufe bei Microsoft.
Der Stockpreis von Snap ist verlagert,
was bedeutet, dass sie wahrscheinlich mehr Läufe haben.
Dann gibt es Elon, der 75% der Twitter-Staff
vertreten hat.
Und essentiell sind alle der großen Tech-Workshops
und Corporations have started to slow hiring.
And that's unlikely to change,
while their stock prices tank as well.
And even the Fed said,
that unemployment needs to go higher.
And you should never fight the Fed.
They're the house that controls our casino economy.
And speaking of casinos, another problematic trend
is the crypto winter.
Bitcoin is down 70% from its high of last year.
That's not a great look for an inflation.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit einen,
der schwört auf Bitcoin.
Der will mir die ganze Zeit erzählen,
ich muss jetzt in Bitcoin investieren.
Weil er weiß,
dass Ende 2024
hat es einen neuen Höchststand.
Da denke ich mir auch so,
warum hast du nicht selbst dein ganzes Geld,
in Bitcoin gesteckt,
wenn du dir da so sicher bist?
Ich meine, hey, kann sein,
kann aber auch nicht sein.
Vielleicht versucht er mich auch zu scammen.
Naja, also,
Bitcoin, das werde ich nix machen.
Oh, NFT-Shit.
Weil NFT ja auch absoluter Bullshit war.
Not a great sign for programming in general.
So in der Form,
wie es da gemacht wurde.
These smart contracts require smart programmers,
but if smart people aren't using them,
then we've got a problem here.
In my opinion, I think Web3
is in the trough of disillusionment,
but will continue to improve and grow in the future.
An even bigger threat to the long-term future.
lives of programmers
is mo-code, no-code and low-code.
So, mo, low.
And we're mo-low.
Das wird auch so ein Ding.
Das ist, wie sie schon seit Jahrzehnten erzählen,
dass jetzt irgendwelche Manager und Personaler
angeblich anfangen,
ihre eigene Anwendung zu programmieren.
Nope.
Auch mit no und low und sonst was Code nicht.
We're low, mo, so, bro.
Programming has kind of evolved
into a blue-collar profession.
It's like being a janitor,
but with less exercise.
Luckily, as of today,
it still pays extremely well.
That's why,
bootcamps like Bloom Institute of Technology,
formerly Lambda School,
can offer a job guarantee of $50,000 a year.
That's nearly $5,000 more than you would make
at McDonald's working for $22 an hour.
Although they also offer a free McBusPass.
The reality, though,
is that technology is now replacing
many of the lines of code
that used to be produced
by humans typing into a keyboard.
There are tons and tons of tools now
that make it possible for non-engineers
to create basic applications,
Web...
Basic, basic vielleicht.
Aber die ganze Logik,
dahinter auch ganz,
das kannst du vergessen.
Du bist,
du brauchst Programmierer
so sehr wie noch nie zuvor
und das wird sich die nächsten Jahre nicht ändern,
eher noch verschlechtern.
...sites and even back-end utilities and databases.
On top of that,
engineers are now writing code
with tools like GitHub Copilot,
which move us closer and closer to obsolescence.
There are no doubt ambitious people out there
foaming at the mouth...
Aber irgendeiner sollte es zumindest noch verstehen,
was GitHub Copilot da ausspuckt.
...of entirely automating your job with AI.
The technology is not there yet,
but just look at it now,
and you'll see that it's not there yet.
But just look at it now,
Look at how far it's come in the last year.
We now have things like stable diffusion in Dolly
and voice cloning that's indistinguishable
from the real thing.
It's only a matter of time,
and when that day comes...
It's over.
We are screwed.
Next up,
we need to talk about social media consolidation,
a trend that's been going on for many years now.
Techlead made a video about this last week,
and you can always trust him
to tell you the things that you don't want to hear.
...and that you think the ability to code is like magic.
Würdest du als einziger IT-Angestellter
ein Fünf-Jahres-Projekt umsetzen wollen?
Nö.
It's not.
We're not wizards.
Nowadays, the vast majority of content creation
has been absorbed by platforms like TikTok,
Twitter and YouTube
that use the follower model for social media.
Why is that?
Well, it incentivizes creators
with money and internet fame.
At a time when...
Haben sie ja gar nicht.
Das war ja eingepackt in Glas.
Die haben das Glas da vor voll geschmiert.
Ja, aber die Idee,
also allein schon auf die Idee zu kommen,
sowas zu machen, finde ich bescheuert.
Aber es ist ja dem Gemälde glücklicherweise nichts passiert.
...common person's attention,
is lower than ever.
Like more than 50% of Americans
have not read a book in the last year.
Das stimmt.
This is a problem for developers
because people are no longer downloading apps
from the App Store every day
or randomly surfing the internet
to find new content.
This makes it extremely difficult
to build a new web or mobile app
and make a ton of money with it
unless you have a massive marketing budget behind it.
Like when oil first became a thing,
there were all kinds of prospectors
becoming overnight millionaires.
But nowadays,
you have a small handful of companies
that control the entire world.
It's a bad trend for independent developers
because it's much harder to make money.
It's even harder to take your side hustle to the moon.
Now, the final trend,
which has also been going on for years,
is the cloud.
You have big cloud platforms like AWS
that have been aggressively simplifying
basically all areas of development.
And until recently,
that's mainly meant fewer jobs
for system administrators and IT guys.
But now, there are many tools coming out
that eliminate both front-end and back-end jobs,
like Honeycode,
which is a no-code tool
for building web and mobile apps.
Also, das sehe ich aktuell auch noch nicht.
Weil letztendlich,
klar,
irgendwo
fallen an manchen Stellen Jobs weg
und ob die dann in der Menge
an anderen Stellen entstehen, okay.
Deswegen sage ich ja auch,
man muss ein bisschen Ahnung haben.
Den 0815 Windows-Klicker
in der 75. Ausführung brauchst du auch nicht.
Aber Leute, die diesen Kram bedienen können,
brauchst du.
Ganz im Ernst,
durchzublicken bei AWS, Azure und Google Cloud
ist schwieriger,
als einen zu finden,
der dir ein paar Windows-Server
und ein paar Linux-Kisten administrieren kann.
Das ist der Grund, warum wir heute hier sind.
Amplify, ein ganzes Backend-Service.
Außerdem haben wir eine Menge neuer Start-ups,
die mit Next-Gen-Serverless-Databasen kommen,
die die Rolle eines Backend-Developers
weiter simplifizieren.
In anderen Worten,
weil neue Cloud-basierte Geräte
die Entwicklung einfacher machen,
gibt es nur weniger Code zu schreiben.
Nun, dieses Video kann sehr pessimistisch klingen,
aber ich denke, es gibt Hoffnung.
Du könntest immer Farmen machen.
Das ist, was Bill Gates gemacht hat,
nachdem er sich von Coding und C-Sharp verletzt hat.
Und jetzt ist er der größte Farmland-Besitzer
in den Vereinigten Staaten.
Ein weiterer Weg von Hoffnung für Millennials
ist, dass Gen-Z ziemlich technisch illiterat ist.
V.a. weil diese Generation aufgewachsen ist
in einer Zeit, in der Social-Media und Technologie
bereits sehr konsolidiert sind.
Wie, ich wette, viele Kinder in diesen Tagen
wissen nicht, wie URLs funktionieren,
oder dass man sie sogar im Browser editieren kann.
Und das ist gute Neuigkeiten für die Bevölkerung.
Das wundert mich auch immer.
Wie planlos heutzutage Leute sind,
die eigentlich mit Technik aufgewachsen sind.
Ich dachte eigentlich, das Problem existiert 2020 nicht mehr.
Eine andere gute Neuigkeit ist,
dass es so aussieht, als würde die 3. Weltkrieg
jeden Tag anfangen.
Anstatt von Frontlinen eingeladen zu werden,
wird ein guter Programmierer
wahrscheinlich
die Software auf Drohnen und Missilien
aufbauen,
während ein guter Web-Developer
die CSS auf Propaganda-Webseiten
aufbauen kann.
Nun, wenn das nicht klappt,
habe ich viel Glauben,
im JavaScript-Ökosystem
eine unendliche Anzahl an Arbeiten zu schaffen,
indem eine unendliche Anzahl
neuer Game-Changer-Frameworks
aufgebaut wird.
Ist es heute eigentlich ein Must-Have,
sich mit Cloud-Zeug auszukennen?
Naja, kommt drauf an.
Ich meine, Cloud-Zeug
ist ja sehr weit gefasst.
Aber du solltest heutzutage zumindest Ahnung haben,
was die ganzen Dinger so grob sind.
Also, wenn dir einer mal fragt,
was ist Cloud-Zeug?
Dann sagst du,
was erzählt von Infrastructure as Code?
Solltest du so eine grobe Vorstellung haben,
was meint der eigentlich?
Mal was mit Terraform
oder Ansible gemacht haben,
ist sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Sich in einer Cloud-Plattform
ganz gut auskennen
und wissen, wo da was ist.
Vielleicht mal irgendwie
so eine Serverless-Function
erstellt haben.
Ja, ist schon nicht verkehrt.
Ist ja eines der Probleme
an diesen ganzen Low-Code-No-Code-Geschichten.
Wenn die Anwendungen komplex sind
und wenn du komplexe Sachen umsetzen willst,
wird das unglaublich groß.
Das ist ungefähr so,
wenn man sich diesen Unreal Blueprint Editor anguckt.
Du kannst 50 Seiten Blueprints machen
oder 20 Zeilen Skript,
so nach dem Motto.
Even if no code did hype train,
even if no code did hypothetically
make all engineers obsolete,
you would still need someone
to code and maintain
all those no-code tools.
Ultimately,
when I take a step back
and look at the big picture,
I see this massively complex ecosystem
of code and technology
that will be impossible
to maintain and push forward
without a massive army
of skilled programmers.
Coding will never be an easy skill.
And many real-world systems
are so over-engineered
that they'll always need
highly specialized
and highly paid engineers
to work on them.
And just like our banking system
still needs COBOL-Developers,
the reality is that code
is just something
the most efficient way
for humans to develop software.
There will always be ups and downs
in terms of opportunity for coders
because of the economy and whatnot.
However, it seems highly unlikely
that the underlying skillset
of writing code
can actually be replaced
by anything in the near future.
Alright, that's enough talking.
I need to get back
to writing some code
with GitHub Copilot.
Thanks for watching.
I'll see you guys in the next video.
Bye.
haben wir noch irgendwas
nächste Woche erster Job mit Remote Setup
auf meinem Laptop, irgendwelche Tipps von euch
was man da vorbereiten könnte
hängt drauf an was das für ein Laden ist wo du anfängst
und wie man sich da einwählt und sonst
kann man jetzt schlecht was sagen
ich hoffe dass das nicht
Windows Only Zeug ist
so haben wir noch irgendwas spannendes
an hier, das da, das da
I leaked my IP Address
ok das kriegen wir jetzt erzählt
lass mich raten, erzählt uns jetzt
dass es nicht schlimm ist seine IP zu leaken
und das ist auch so, das ist nicht schlimm seine IP zu leaken
dumm ist nur wenn man live streamt
seine IP leakt und irgendwelche Leute
seine China Chinesen Bots
anwirft und man da nicht weiter
streamen kann, aber ok, ok zeigt mal her
Leaking your IP Address
really dangerous
extrem dangerous
because when I released my Minecraft Hacking Video Series
I kept leaking
my personal IP
oh nein, IP leaked
as well as many other players
oops, sorry
after that I got tons of worrying messages
telling me about it
I should immediately remove it
but how bad is it really
I believe it's not bad at all
and my suspicion is
that the crazy amount of VPN Ads
manipulate people into believing
it is dangerous or bad
ja das hat auf jeden Fall was
da beschleunigt in der Richtung
ja da denke ich, da könnte er schon recht haben
so in this video I want to investigate
this danger of leaking your IP Address
ich habe eine NordVPN Placement Anfrage in den E-Mails
auf geht's
in the end I will also tell you my recommendation
on what you could do instead of a VPN
as always these are just my opinions on the matter
the devil is in the technical details
so feel free to challenge my views
and discuss with others in the comments
this video is sponsored by
NordVPN
nobody, of course I wouldn't advertise a VPN in this video
das wäre es jetzt nämlich gewesen, Lugg
sorry, I had to do that
anyway, where do we start
in theory IP Addresses are unique
and identify a computer on the internet
for example a Minecraft
außer man hat carrier, äh, Dings, ähm
DSLite mit carrier create NAT
dann ist das so schwierig
...adress
this part
okay, im Prinzip ist das ja eine IPv6
eine IPv4 in IPv6 Tunnel
IP it identifies the computer
so where to find the server on the internet
and this is the port
The port is then used on that computer to find which program you want to communicate.
Und das zusammen ist ein Socket.
For a Minecraft server, it's the Minecraft server program.
On the same computer you could also host a website.
And then the web server program would be accessible on maybe port 80.
But we want to focus on the IP address.
As you can see, IPs are supposed to be addresses for devices on the Internet.
And so they are inherently public.
For example, I didn't release the IP address of my Minecraft server.
And still people found it.
Because it's easy to scan all IPv4 addresses on the Internet.
And that's our first lesson.
How much can you even hide your IP?
If there's anything insecure about your device,
if you really believe a hacker can hack you when they know your IP,
you are screwed anyway.
People will find your device regardless.
But don't worry.
Not only are you a hacker,
but also are modern devices generally secure.
You have another layer of protection you might not know about.
Allein schon, weil die meisten Leute, die IPv4 verwenden,
noch ihre 0815-Provider-Router davor haben,
was ja im Prinzip immer noch mal
NAT auf Router-Seite bedeutet,
passiert da eigentlich nix.
Ja, es sei denn, du livestreamst
und irgendwelche Leute kriegen deine IP raus
und werfen ihre China-Chinesen-Bots an.
Yes.
Und spammen dich zu.
Ja, also ich konnte schon beispielsweise mal
eine halbe Stunde nicht streamen, richtig,
weil ich meine IP geleakt habe
und irgendwelche Leute ihre DOS-DDoS-Tools angeschmissen haben.
Aber gut.
Directly accessible via an IP-Address.
But as you probably have heard,
we don't have enough IP-Addresses for all devices on the Internet.
How did we try to solve that problem?
You can see it here.
I have two phones connected to the same Wi-Fi
and I look up their IP-Address.
Both phones have the same IP.
Ja.
And this is very common for residential Internet connections.
So, the IP does not actually identify every device.
It's just the address of the device
directly connected to the Internet.
Usually at home, this is your router.
Which means, this single IP does not point to your device,
it points to the router.
Das war früher tatsächlich ein Problem,
zu Zeiten, als man sich noch DSL direkt eingewählt hat,
beispielsweise von seinem Computer.
Das war früher tatsächlich ein Problem, zu Zeiten, als man sich noch DSL direkt eingewählt hat,
sowie deine Windows Rechner aus.
Da gab es ganz viele Sicherheitsprobleme.
Die Leute haben ihr DSL Modem direkt angeschlossen auf einen Windows Rechner
und du hattest auf deinem Windows Rechner die Public IP.
Und ich glaube zu Hochzeiten hat es ungefähr
im durchschnitt 37 Sekunden gedauert,
dass ein frisch installierter Windows XP Rechner unbenutzbar war.
Im Internet.
Also, ein frisch installierter Windows XP Rechner,
dem du ins Internet gehängt hast,
hast, war eben, glaube ich, im Durchschnitt nach 37 Sekunden im Arsch.
Behind this address, there could be dozens of devices. And in a larger shared flat or
a college dorm, hotel or in an office, maybe several hundreds of devices and different
people use the same IP. This is achieved through NAT. It's an interesting technique and quite
clever how routers translate packets and forward them to the correct local device. There are
also some very interesting weaknesses in NAT, which get exploited for good reasons,
like UDP hole punching for playing games, or for bad malicious reasons like NAT slipstreaming.
But that's not the topic of the video. The important part is that the IP address...
Na, Alter, anschauen, dass so Zeug wie WebRTC Videokonferenz und sowas ordentlich funktioniert
von einem Endgerät zum anderen Endgerät, ohne dass es permanent über einen Zwischenserver
gehen muss. Geht nur mit Tricks über NAT.
...is shared by NAT.
...in many devices and often shared by many different people, which has legal implications.
If you have roommates and you commit a crime, they don't know who exactly committed the
crime. Was it you or your roommate? Depending on your local laws, maybe this means they
cannot prove who committed it, and you are safe, or maybe both of you get raided, or
by...
In Deutschland bist du dann gefickt, wahrscheinlich weil es dein Internetanschluss ist.
...and therefore they are charging the owner of the WiFi. Check your local laws.
But besides the legal trouble. Point being.
Your public IP address, the address website owners and Minecraft-Server owners see, might
be used by many different people. So this is the second lesson. The same IP does not
mean it's the same person. Of course, if you live alone, things might be different
and you don't have this legal protection. However, some ISPs...
Einfach public WLAN aufmachen, dann hat man immer ein paar Gäste.
...started to deploy DSLite. It's very common in Germany.
Boah, hör mal auf, ich hab's am Anfang schon gesagt.
Keck, wait!
This is when IPv4 is downloaded by IPv6, leading to another layer of NAT, or carrier-grade
NAT.
No, God!
Which means, behind this public IP, there might be hundreds of customers.
No, God, please, no!
Each of them with...
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass die Ausgänge bei Unity Media Vodafone, diese NAT-Ausgänge,
die heißen AFTER, was ich irgendwie ein unglücklicher Name für einen Ausgang finde, aber gut.
Vodafone fand's wahrscheinlich lustig.
Nee, es ist irgendeine Abkürzung.
Aber...
Ich finde, es ist eine blöde Abkürzung für den NAT-Ausgang.
Endpunkt.
Dozens of devices.
And don't forget, lots of people use the Internet through LTE.
Here, your mobile operator also probably shares IP addresses...
Na, zum Glück, zum Glück nicht 5G.
Sonst wären wir jetzt alle verstrahlt.
Zum Glück nur LTE.
...for many connected devices.
So, ich glaube, das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
die auf unbestimmte zeit ich glaube du musst dein router irgendwie ein paar stunden ausschalten
beziehungsweise abstöpseln dass du neue kriegs bei connect side operators in your ip they don't know
if it's exactly you and the next day you might have a different ip anyway but of course all of
these things depend on the isp and probably every country has different behavior as well so the best
thing for you is just to test it yourself also i've read in the comments on the minecraft video
that there are a few people that actually have a static ip though usually that requires a special
contract or a business contract and i would guess wie gesagt bei vodafone ändert sich die ip einfach
nicht oft know what they are doing and know why they want a static ip by that i mean they want a
static ip so people can know the static ip and then if you worry about people knowing your static ip
don't get a static ip ja da ist was dran also people who had no choice for a static ip
but then again what exactly are you worrying about we will get to these threats in a moment but
for most people the ip address changes regularly and it just identifies the home router or a router
of your isp or mobile operator so leaking an ip address doesn't really mean much there could be
literally hundreds of people behind that ip this actually creates a lot of problems when blocking
malicious ip addresses because if you as a website owner block an ip you might accidentally
block a whole area like a hotel or office so blocking hundreds of people from using your
service anyway now that we have covered some important properties of ip addresses let's talk
about the impact of leaking ip addresses what's the leaked model i see in two areas hacking or
attacking ips and the more privacy concern also also ich als jemand der streamt ich habe tatsächlich
schon öfters mal dedos probleme gehabt wenn ich mal aus versehen
geliebt habe weil ich mal wieder ssh beim login nicht ausgeschaltet habe das ist die ip anzeige
da hat es gab es immer ein paar leute die konnten es nicht lassen und mussten mich damit irgendeine
müll zu spammen aber gut ist ja meistens nicht lange already tell if you leak the ip address of
a person the ip address could mean different things it could just point to your router of the isp or
could point to your home router and attacking the home router might be the most risky case because
outdated router with some exposed services or default credentials that could be hacked or it
can be directly targeted for denial of service attack so maybe you feel worried about your
unsecure router and think that it's a good reason why you need to keep your ip private but keep in
mind all ip addresses are public there are not that many you can literally scan the whole internet in
like half an hour and malicious hackers constantly scan the internet for vulnerable routers to take
them over so if there is a known exploit
ipv6 points dann auf direkt auf das end device ja meistens oder sagen wir mal so je nachdem wie
es gemacht ist aber du hast auf jeden fall genug ipv6 adressen ja du hast dann zumindest meistens
meistens ja keine nach geschichten mehr dazwischen das heißt du brauchst auf jeden fall irgendwelche
sinnvoll default eingestellten firewall regeln auf deinem router das eben von außen nichts
standardmäßig durchgeleitet wird was du nicht angefragt hast
already be hacked and if not then maybe your isp knows about the issue and blocks these attempts
on their end so security issues are not really a concern and if it is you need to fix the root
issue security through obscurity aka trying to hide your ip doesn't fix it however maybe you
don't worry about security issues but about denial of service attacks it's easy to overwhelm a basic
home router but as i said in lots of cases the ip doesn't even point at your security issues
at your home router at this point an attacker maybe yeah bei mir schon ich habe ja einen
richtig echten dual stack kein dual stack lite it might knock you off the internet temporarily
and for some businesses or streamers this has economical consequences but that's all
there is go outside touch some grass and when you come back maybe it's stopped and you can
continue you have no actual loss of privacy or security there ja das stimmt ist aber trotzdem
kacke wenn man streamen will und kann nicht maybe restart your router gives you a new ip anyway
but are there other privacy concerns vpn companies always advertise protecting your privacy by
hiding your ip but as we already learned in lots of cases the home ip is already achieving the
same it's also public ip shared by many other customers so from the point of view of the
internet user who sees that ip you are already kind of obscured but of course there are some
differences between a vpn and an isp so let's go through them the probably most important
difference section is the legal jurisdiction depending on a country's laws isps might
be required to keep logged on which
ja das stimmt und viele vpn anbieter sagen sie speichern keine logs allerdings tja ist
halt die frage ob du so einem vpn anbieter vertraust dass das wirklich nicht so ist und
was passiert wenn man dem wirklich mal die sonder einsatz sondereinsatzkommando vor der
tür steht seht die dann nicht auf einmal doch super kooperativ also da ist halt einfach
die aussage da vom vpn anbieter und ob das dann wirklich so ist oder ist das irgendwie
so ist oder ist das eigentlich richtig oder ist das eigentlich nicht richtig also da
ist halt einfach die aussage da vom vpn anbieter und ob das dann wirklich so ist oder ist es
natürlich so dass es sich nicht so ведert ob du den vpn anbieter auch nicht so gut entwickelt
dann wirklich so ist? Who knows.
Also ich hab gelesen, dass
VPNs in den Iran
aktuell irgendwie
voll im Trend sind.
Wobei ich mich frage, wie das
gehen soll. Die haben ja ziemliche Internetzensurprobleme.
Aber hab ich vor ein paar Monaten
was drüber gelesen, dass VPN-Anbieter
im Iran aktuell wohl gerade
recht angesagt werden.
Das sag ich ja auch schon. Ich hab ja sogar
ein Video drüber gemacht,
wo dann im Endeffekt NordVPN
gesagt hat, wenn du jemals in Sponsoring
machen willst mit uns, musst du das Video löschen.
Mach ich natürlich nicht. Aber
ja, so ist es. Hat schon recht.
Man bildet sich da viel
mehr Schutz ein, als es eigentlich
bringt. Aber die Werbung ist halt auch sehr
irreführend.
So nach dem Motto,
es wäre alles super sicher, es wäre alles
zusätzlich verschlüsselt. Ist ja gar nicht.
Es ist der Weg zwischen dir und dem VPN-Anbieter
zusätzlich verschlüsselt. Aber wenn du
normale Webseiten über HTTPS verwendest,
ist es eh egal. Und danach
vom Eingang, beziehungsweise
vom Ausgang des VPNs zum Zielzauber
ist es, wenn es vorher unverschlüsselt war, nachher auch
unverschlüsselt. Also insofern macht eigentlich
gar keinen wirklichen Unterschied.
Wie gesagt, um Geoblocking-Sachen
zu empgehen und so. Da, VPN haben schon
seine Anwendungsgebiete. Aber das, was
das angeblich alles Tolles macht,
ist zum größten Teil Blödsinn.
Thanks to SSL anyway.
In my opinion, the privacy risk
is not that high. And for the legal
risk, that depends a lot on what crime
you commit.
As you can see, in the end, it all comes
down to trust. Where do
you want your pockets to travel?
Also ich vertraue prinzipiell nur dem Twitch-Chat.
Do you trust your ISP more
or the VPN provider more?
You have to make that decision yourself.
Also I think it's important to not forget
what it means to have a...
Wie würde man sich selbst dann am besten schützen, wenn nicht mit
einem VPN? Die Frage ist ja erstmal, vor was
musst du dich schützen? Musst du dich überhaupt schützen?
Vor was willst du dich schützen? Was willst du machen?
Willst du irgendwelche Straftaten
begehen? Tja.
Da ist wahrscheinlich das Sinnvollste,
was du machen kannst, irgendwelche Tor-Browser-
Geschichten, aber
ansonsten, vor was willst
du dich schützen? Also es gibt ja
eigentlich so in normaler Weise wenig, wovor man sich
schützen müsste und wo einer ein VPN vorschützt.
Das Einzige, was man
mit einem VPN tatsächlich ganz
gut machen kann, ist halt
Geoblocking umgehen. Wobei man das natürlich
auch selbst ohne Probleme machen kann.
Man kann sich auch irgendwie einen Server mieten.
Beispielsweise mein YouTube
Premium.
Schließe ich ja auch immer über
Indien ab und das mache ich über
einen SSH-SOX-Proxy
mit einer
VM Digital Ocean in
Bangalore, Indien.
Da erstelle ich mir alle paar Monate mal eine
VM. Mittlerweile habe ich ja ein Dauer-Abo.
Eine VM
und dann per SSH-SOX-Proxy
verbinden
mit einem Browser und dann hat man halt
eine indische IP.
Und dann kann man eben YouTube Premium
über Indien kaufen und mit indischen
Rupien glaube ich
bezahlen und das kostet dann plus 3 Euro
anstatt 12 Euro.
Bangalore, genau.
Ob man das auch so ausspricht, weiß nicht.
Ist das denn erlaubt? Warum nicht?
Es geht.
Rupien. Es gibt ja nichts
wirklich, wofür du dich schützen musst.
Braucht man eine indische
Kreditkarte? Nein, braucht man nicht.
Kann über Paypal bezahlen.
Oder? Oder Kreditkarte?
Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht.
Zumindest braucht man ein neues Payment-Profil.
Im Google-Account
ein neues Payment-Profil.
Das musst du auf Indien stellen, dann geht's.
Privacy-Issue.
Privacy-Issues arise when you share
private information.
So what private information does your IP
leak? If you use Facebook
and Instagram to share private photos,
it doesn't matter if you use a VPN
or your regular IP. You still share
your private photos online.
So the actions you do online
are much more important than the IP.
The only thing the IPs do is that they share your private photos.
The only thing the IP leaks is your location.
But this is a bit misleading, because
what do you mean by location?
It doesn't leak your exact GPS coordinates.
It might point to the city you live in,
but most likely it points to the region
where tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of people live.
Of course, some might want to
completely hide their general location
and don't want anybody to know they live
in Berlin, but I don't think
this is generally an issue most people
have to care about. Think about
normal people. They post a single
picture on Instagram from hiking near
their home and people could figure out
their general location.
So, let's talk about me leaking the IP addresses
of players on my Minecraft server.
How bad was it? In my opinion,
some of those IP addresses are dynamic
and changed long before I uploaded
the video. And some of these IP
addresses are shared with hundreds of
people anyway. Of course, it might
leak the rough geographic location
of some players, but maybe they don't care or
they leaked it in many other ways.
For example, oh my god,
here I leaked the famous
automated IP address
because I'm so famous he came onto
my server. Now we can geolocate
him to Seattle.
Oh my god.
Anzeige ist raus.
But, besides
all of that, are you ready
for a last argument? Hast du Call of Duty Stream von
Alotrix gesehen? Nee.
Warum? Why me leaking the IP addresses
of players on the server is not
bad? If one of those
players really, really cared about hiding
their tracks online, being super
paranoid, they must have used the VPN
to access the server anyway.
As you can see, in my
opinion, there's no meaningful security
risk or meaningful privacy
issue about leaking IPs.
There are crazy edge cases with
very weird threat models. Naja, diese Region,
die angezeigt wird, das kommt aus irgendwelchen
Datenbanken, wo das halt mal jemand zugeordnet
hat. Du machst da so einen reverse look up.
Das muss nicht zwangsläufig immer
super akkurat sein. Also bei mir
stimmt's ganz gut.
Er sagt ja meistens irgendwie grobe Region
Hanau, Frankfurt. Grünstliche
Hardware-Bezugsquellen, naja, guck's
bei AliExpress. Er hat enttäuscht
den Stream abgebrochen.
Okay.
Also wenn
ich einem truste, dann prinzipiell
eh nur dem Twitch-Chat.
If your threat model is
cannot trust anything I connect to
online, then don't connect to it.
Don't use your home IP,
whatever you consider your home IP.
Okay, anyway. Now many of you
watching probably also screamed the whole time
is he talking about IPv4 or
IPv6? And well, yeah, most of
what I mentioned mostly applies to IPv4.
Due to them running out
and many customers will share IP
addresses, leading to the ISP
setups discussed in this video.
With IPv6,
the game kind of changes.
And to be honest, I'm not super sure how
ISP setups look like with IPv6.
The little bit of networking knowledge I have
is mostly limited to IPv4.
But I guess depending on...
Wird die ungefähre Position nicht vom Provider
angegeben? Nee, aber du
kennst halt so gewisse
IP-Netz und weißt so ungefähr in welche
Richtung die sind. Da gibt's ja Datenbanken, wo du das
nach, so irgendwelche Geolocation-Datenbanken,
wo du das nachgucken kannst. Die müssen
aber nicht immer, sondern nicht korrekt sein.
Und wie du irgendwie...
Triangulation machen willst
mit meiner IP daheim, das verstehe
ich auch nicht so genau.
Willst du dir
verschiedene...
Okay, naja, vielleicht.
Aber dafür sind die Laufzeiten noch viel zu
unpräzise.
Also du müsstest dir dann
theoretisch verschiedene Server in Deutschland
mieten, wo du den genauen Standort kennst
und dann müsstest du mich irgendwie
anpingen und dann müsstest du hoffen,
dass die Route bekannt ist, die du nimmst
und das ist immer die
klassische
Gleiche ist. Also, dass das
wirklich nennenswert was bringt,
bezweifle ich. Also, viel genauer
als die grobe Region, die du meistens
aus so einem Reverse-Lookup über so eine
Geodatenbank rauskriegst, wird das
auch nicht... wird das das auch nicht
bringen.
Zumal, was machst du, wenn der Router nicht auf
Ping antwortet? Also, ich glaube
nicht, dass das großartig was bringt.
Kommt noch was?
Okay, das war's.
Aber gut, er hat komplett
recht mit allem, was er sagt.
Wenn du...
Okay, es... Leute, ich hab Hunger!
Es ist kurz vor
zwölf, theoretisch, ja?
Aber ich kann jetzt noch nichts essen.
Ich mein, es ist 10.35 Uhr. The fuck?
Moment, das hatten wir doch
grad schon.
Das hatten wir doch nicht.
Wollen wir nicht gucken?
Wollen wir auch nicht gucken?
Lisp in... Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Codeine is dead.
Jetzt haben wir schon geguckt.
Habe ich jetzt auch keinen Bock drauf.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Keinen Bock drauf.
Das Video von Stacksman... Nee, 20 Minuten zu sowas.
Habe ich jetzt keinen Bock.
Ich hab Hunger. Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Gehst du heute wieder spazieren?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Heute ist gutes Wetter.
Normalerweise sonntags nicht,
aber heute werde ich meine
zwei Stunden Bewegung wahrscheinlich wieder machen.
Ich glaube, ich esse jetzt doch was.
Lull.
Lull. Auf geht's.
Nee, wir...
Wir gucken jetzt nichts mehr.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, ähm, nee, also ich muss heute.
Heute ist nix mit wandern.
Ich muss heute ein bisschen MW2 spielen und meinen Senf dazugeben.
Bleibt nichts anderes übrig.
Muss jetzt, muss jetzt mal sein.
Muss ich durch, auch wenn ich gar nicht so wirklich Bock drauf habe.
Du hast ein totes Pixel auf meinem MacBook.
Ich weiß nicht, wie da die Garantie aussieht.
Keine Ahnung.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern bzw.
warten, quälen mich noch eine Stunde und dann gehe ich was futtern.
Bis denn, Leute. Macht's gut.
See you.